a lady that was blind from birth 5%
vision but the only event seen what we
call modern medicine is essentially
unscientific nonsense it's what I saw
first time in the scientific history
after 250 years of data they so for the
first time that the human physiology now
is capable of influencing deeply into
the autonomic nervous system that
related to the immune system means that
we are going to look completely
different to to work disease and to work
pain I I did it
I teach doctor sir nowadays and
therapists and awake with her professors
and I only have a technical school I
learned to pain but I believed I
believed we can do more and we think we
can in the third year of the university
books in a in the USA all the
universities they have included a
chapter calling the Iseman it's about me
meanwhile they explained a comparative
study as you saw these young people just
trained in four days time to be able to
influence deeply into the autonomous
nervous system and bacteria injected
therefore had no chance within a quarter
of our compared to thousands of tests
subjects before and now these persons I
trade in four days in four days they
were very capable to injure say the cold
to minus 27 on top of a big mountain in
shorts dancing the Harlem shake all of
them and yes then I knew I was convinced
hey these guys they are back and have
tapped into their deeper potential the
way nature mantid to be in every person
but they did it and awakened it and four
days later they were in the hospital yes
they were injected and they had
hundred-percent score everybody had a
control over the immune system in the
deepest levels not recognized by science
up till then to be possibly influenced
and they did it all and so I did it also
with 26 people ranging to 65 years from
22 years having all kinds of diseases
like chrome Romo MS cancer asthma
coronary disease bypasses and all that
and all the physiologists and experts
they told us it's not possible to do
that we don't want to link our name with
your expedition the people are going to
die this is not possible to be done and
yes maybe they are right we didn't do it
in three days we did it in two days I
don't hear these experts anymore they
thought it to be that way
we got these old ways of thinking
patterns and they are laying it upon us
you cannot do this you cannot do you've
got to do this you've got to do this
industries who gain a lot of money
because and I don't want to be political
but this is the old way of thinking and
the food industry and the medicine
industry
they are really not here to feed us or
to heal us they are here to make money
and so maybe still has to come here you
know substantially in the in the books
here in the Netherlands but USA already
is doing this and soon we have a new
studies with Harvard
it's all in there you want to be happy
and you translated into chemistry you
see
opposite of seeing melatonin and
serotonin de Mathilde trip to mind all
those hormones when you see power energy
you see a trillion epinephrine and
cortisol and all that so actually we
don't need so much technology anymore we
don't need all these medicines we have
our own we have to go back to the inner
nature the way nature has meant it to be
this time we are going to showed
scientifically that we are able to make
happen our own happiness strength and
health for our children and for the
earth thank you
and you have been named Britain's best
therapist by many magazines you worked
with a lot of superstars rock stars
helping them overcome a lot of their
challenges and be better performers why
did you get into this field in the first
place
I was very interesting I used to teach
aerobics the Jane Fonda hearing Millard
South Robertson yeah many moons ago
which I have to say was way more fun
yeah a child psychologist in the north
of England but I had a psychology
background I've always been fascinated
by human behavior and I noticed in her
studio she'd be the first to admit it
every third woman was bulimic and
anorexic including Jane who was
believing for a long time so they were
bulimic and anorexic exercise composable
body dysmorphia to go look at this fat
on my wrists or skin i know it's yeah
but to them it was fat so I found this
genius hypnotherapist group Gil born out
in Glendale and I trained with him I
thought oh this is like amazing I've got
all these people in my class I have all
these issues and I've got this
hypnotherapy training and all I have to
do is take all my clients straight out
of my classes which I did with immense
success and then I worked on several TV
shows wrote some books and then thought
you know there's only me doing this so I
should teach other people to do it and
now I teach lots of people to do because
now I've created my own method which is
really taking the world by storm what's
it called it's go rapid transformational
therapy how does it work well it works
by so for instance if you have migraines
or you're a beast and you go to a
therapist they want you to talk every
week about how it what's it like being a
nice and very distressing actually and
what does that feel like frustrating
it's like you're going to the dentist's
Inc and I come in every week and talk
about the infection in my gum the
dentist goes no get that infection out
because it just does ongoing damage so
conventional therapy likes to talk
and what I don't like about conventional
though is like okay you you have bipolar
that's very complex therefore the
treatment is going to be very complex
and that is not the case we're taking in
stage and conventional medicine to they
treat the symptoms was when I work with
someone who's believed he can go what
happened what happened you to go well my
granddad had sex with when I was 11
until I was 13 and I got really fat and
I never realized the connection I kept
saying I wish I could stop him looking
at me like that and the mind goes that's
the command you want your granddad to
stop lusting after your body I make your
body super unattractive yeah and then of
course when the when the symptom has a
role function purpose and an intention
it's not going anywhere so the raw so if
someone has headaches you would walk
them through what's the role then hey
what's the benefit yeah what's the
payoff even with children of five if I
say to a five-year-old maybe I know this
is a silly question but if the headache
was your friend what would it be doing
they go well
when mummy and daddy fight and I got a
headache they stopped fighting they turn
off all the lights and we lie in the
dark till it goes away there's a kid
who's had a thought
I gotta stop mommy and daddy fighting
and because they're they're not logical
creatures they're feeling creatures a
feeling mind says an illness will stop
your parents fighting may be failing at
school will make them see that you're
unhappy maybe getting axonal rating I'm
spent ages massaging the cream into your
skin and you might feel that you matter
to her because every time you speaking
to her I'm busy at work I'm doing my
emails I got to speak to work and kids
think I want mommy to notice me in the
mind which is illogical goes can I come
up with what we can have asthma eczema
dermatitis irritable bowel obesity yeah
and 70% of these issues although the
symptoms are real you have a real
migraine and real flaky skin the cause
of them is completely psychos
matic because the minds job is to tune
in to your thoughts and give you what it
thinks you want and we don't understand
that the brain has no sense of humor and
only picks up words and thinks they're
real yeah hello what we're talking about
with dr. Joe Dispenza Wow okay so you
started helping people from one phase
which was in losing weight you
understand people it's much more than
just losing away yeah yeah why did you
why were you so fascinated by human
behavior in the first place well I was
told I could never have children I just
when I was 17 I stopped having periods
completely and all the doctor said we
know you you have infertility
unexplained which I thought that's a
good title isn't it I screamed because
explained is your fallopian tubes are
blocked or you don't have enough
estrogen but unexplained means
everything's working we have no idea
what's going on and so I decided to just
work on myself and I simply wouldn't
accept that and I did get pregnant but
then they said well everything's would
be wrong with this baby and it's gonna
have the same issues that you've got
you've got all these different hormone
or thyroid issues and and they really
freaked me out and then when she was
born she was perfectly swish she's gonna
be very underweight 7 1/2 pounds and I
realized then I was gonna stop all the
medication and just come out of that
because since you say it you can say
something they say yeah and our feelings
of the most real thing we have and we
push them down we found all this stuff
to buy or eat or drink or take to keep
us like John Lennon said comfortably
numb' but then the feelings regroup and
come back because they've always got a
job to do and I would say to my clients
look you've got to feel the feeling
until it no longer requires to be felt
you can't eat it or drink it or shop it
away but we're all taught that we can
and should because I have something I
call Triple A which is aware of you're
feeling miserable have no idea what they
feel the guy shouldn't feel jealous I
shouldn't feel envious I shouldn't be
furious with this kid who's keeping me
up all night
so they're not aware of it they
certainly can't accept and they never
get to articulate really because we are
wired to like what is familiar and to
resist what's unfamiliar and that's what
kept us alive when we lived in waters
you didn't go I'm bit bored with this
group I think I'll go outside the water
city and find another tribe because they
might have killed you so we have this
wiring that says run towards what's
familiar and run away from what's
unfamiliar but the very good news is you
can make anything familiar and the most
important thing to make familiar is
praising yourself that's if you could
just do that that in itself would change
your entire life whatever you wanted to
hear
say it to yourself cuz your mind doesn't
even know that it's coming and also it
doesn't care your mind doesn't care what
you tell it is right or wrong or true or
false or even if it's good or bad it
lets it in like chapstick on your lips
your lips don't go is this organic
Fairtrade just let sit in it it needs a
bit of nourishment and we need some
nourishment and words are very
nourishing and there is actually nothing
on the planet that will raise your
self-esteem like praise understand
almost yeah it's not a challenge to get
more people to understand it because
people need it you know we all need to
be nourished you know we need intr we
need nourishment our soul needs to be
know she's not about organic avocados
from an l1 market that's great but we
all need this emotional nourishment so
is it a challenge getting more people to
accept it I don't think it is because
everyone I seek oh my god I love that so
they know I I listen to youth of this
rubbish but then I find myself going
into the garage and say nice stuff to
myself so maybe my only challenge will
even then it's not a challenge as I
would say half the medical profession
love what I do
and really go for it go my god this is
amazing I'm using with my own patients
the other half get this is all silly you
know what illness is caused by disease
that you can't talk yourself better
talking to yourself doesn't make any
difference you can't possibly give birth
just using positive
Asians it's like if you had cancer and
you had a very good oncologist you might
go look you know the way you think the
way you eat the way you act the way you
rest can all affect I'm good no you got
cancer chemotherapy there's nothing else
that will work and all that stuff is
hocus-pocus so that is a challenge but
it's not so much because I find say many
doctors love what I do and go Wow
now all these illnesses autoimmune
illnesses many years ago there was a
wonderful psychiatrist in London called
dr. Maudsley and he had a great
expression so as with my favorite and it
says the feeling that cannot find its
expression in tears may cause other
organs to weep so he knew 100 years ago
that's beautiful so beautiful and so
true the feeling that cannot find its
expression in tears will cause other
organs to weeps
easier to say if you don't feel the
feeling you know what is gonna feel it
if you don't open your mouth and say you
hurt me don't be surprised if you get a
screaming everywhere I've got the
screaming headache I've got this angry
red rash I've got this thumping pain and
by the words they're using angry
screaming they're saying I have rage
that can't come out expressing
everything yeah yeah because the body is
very clever at finding something I
worked as someone who couldn't walk and
all chefs I can't stand there I can't
stand my ex I can't stand my love I
can't stand my kisses and you can't
stand up
isn't that interesting she had sort of
phantom leg pains because she couldn't
stand anything believers will say well
what makes me sick is my sister-in-law
rocks so sick of her she just makes me
sick
I've vomit in my mouth every time I hear
a voice and then they wonder why they're
bulimic right because our words that
really affect our reality
partly because and it's such an easy
thing to say every word you say is a
blueprint that your mind body inside
here working to meet your reality so we
make our thoughts and our thoughts may
cast let me go out into the world and we
justify our thoughts every day but we
are words through a blueprint and when
you know that you think we'll I better
pay attention to that blueprint I better
not say this kid is killing me my job is
making me want to die there on the flip
side of this the beautiful part if we
when we understand and appreciate that
our thoughts yeah yeah we can create the
life of our dreams as well we can start
by linearizing by telling ourselves what
we want we want to become you know
taking those actions toward it we can
manifest our dream you really can you
couldn't stop being ill you can change
the shape of your body you can change
your digestion what do you say yourself
on a daily basis is there like a process
in the morning after you know what it'd
be like actually when I wake up the
first thing I would says I love my life
I love my linen and I love my cup of tea
I always wake up going I love my life
and then when I meet my goal of this D I
love the coffee I love the shower gel in
my shower because I I really believe
that if you can make your mind get
excited by little things then big things
every day is like Christmas and I think
when you wake up you should oh what have
I got today Oh a world of stress I've
got this this this this this so you
should always wake up and go I love my
life I'm alive and a free country I've
got all this stuff to make tea and life
is great so that I do that but I think
it's important for people to understand
that it isn't what you do it's a bit
like people who say I've done yoga every
day and now it's just my soul like Megan
Marc will said that yoga is in my soul I
don't do yoga yoga is part of my life
it's like you don't say I walk my dog if
you've had a dog for 20 s just get up
figure out the lead and it's it's who
you are not what you do was rubber
something in the last 10 years that
questioned everything that you've done
or that question your ability to say I
love my life you know I did get very
sick like a year ago and I thought well
how could that happen you know I'm so
happy and positive and eat well so I was
a bit surprised when I got sick
but then I look at Ruth at the same
thing the thinking the belief I decided
I'd focus on massive healing I kept
telling my body but it was a cancer
fighting machine was making all these NK
killer cells and I did actually go home
the next day I was on stage a week later
and my doctor was like wow you become
the poster girl for just getting on with
your life and now I look at one
particular you to burden that supers I
had like major surgery just a week
before that and you never know but again
it it's it's a belief I decided I do
wellness I says well I need to go home I
want and I went I'm a goner in bed I
watched ray Donovan I think this is it
I'm doing wellness here I'm not gonna
lie in that bed where they keep trying
to give you pills and I didn't feel any
pain at all cuz I just kept telling my
body to heal itself and then later I
thought maybe it's good I got that
because I can help other people and I go
look you know it life throws stuff at
you but you get to choose how to deal
with it
and even then I noticed that I was very
positive because I you know I had
actually got womb cancer little stroke
of luck to get wound count so I don't
need a womb it's done its job I've had a
great kid I talked to my womb and said
thanks for giving me this great kid but
now I got to get rid of you because I
got to stay here and raise this great
kid and I thought that's good I mean
imagine if you get brain cancer or bone
cancer I felt very lucky was it
disposable organ they've done a great
job I didn't need it and so I think once
you become like that it's just who you
are so I never had oh my god I'm gonna
die because I don't know I'm not going
anywhere
it is all perspective I mean I still you
know people will say to me but I thought
you were so healthy how could you get
that as it turns out I have some that
same gene that Angelina Jolie has but
but then of course Bruce Lipton will
tell you can turn off a gene you can you
can mentally remove that gene so even
with adversity because it's quite good
annoyed because we'll think all your
life stirs you like Pollyanna just
tripping along having a wonderful life
that's not true I've still had adversity
but your mind will always kick in when
it's wild
crane you know this is a blip just it's
just a blip just carry on and so you got
to train your mind like you trading a
horse you know I say your mind's like a
Ferrari and if you've never driven a
Ferrari it's gonna go all over the place
but if you have Ferrari driving lessons
you're gonna run that Ferrari the
Ferrari should not be running you but
but actually I don't need to see clients
anymore because I used to really know I
had a gift for what I do but the way I
teach my method is something that you
can replicate and we have amazing
therapists all over the world many in
Los Angeles who are so good I mean
getting phenomenal results with people
with impetigo and vitiligo and ringing
in the ears tinnitus all kinds and stuff
depression anxiety insomnia
how did I get into this I used to be a
bodybuilder 215 percent and 3 percent
body fat and this was my foray into
trying to figure out how to get the most
out of the human body and brain being
able to pose on stage and I felt
absolutely horrible right you're
crapping out a straw and you have no sex
drive and your big slab of meat that
lays on the couch but that was my foray
into physical culture was bodybuilding
and this is what I do that ultimate
marriage of ancestral wisdom and modern
science to enhance longevity no actually
seriously I've I test my telomere length
I test my telomere length which is a
measurement of the the average length of
the of the telomeres that cap the the
DNA when I was 34 I tested my biological
age right so at a chronological age of
34 my biological age when I tested via
telomeres was 37 and then I tested again
when I was 35 and my biological age had
dropped to 36 my last tests and again
this was implementing a lot of the stuff
I'm going to show you at 36 years old I
had a biological age of 20 that was my
goal to get to by the time I was 40
years old so on the head of the curve
but the idea that you can be at a
chronological age but look feel and
perform as though you're at a much
younger biological age is something we
can attain and something we can test
with telomere length 3 sections how to
optimize your mind how to optimize your
body and how to optimize your spirit I'm
gonna go over some of my most potent
tips for each of these body mind and
spirit as we go so next is a book by dr.
Ben Lynch it's called dirty genes on how
certain people have different genetic
factors that can keep you from
metabolizing certain things or that can
keep you from responding to certain
things such as coffee or alcohol
anything that you might consume in in a
beneficial way so for example I found
from that book that my body responds
poorly
alcohol I know that I don't drink a lot
of alcohol ray Krone eyes who worked
with the previous speaker here wim HOF
Ray Krone ice has a specific hot cold
contrast shower I took one this morning
as soon as I woke up all you do is 20
seconds of cold - ten seconds hot ten
times through in working with a lot of
his clients he was able to not only
strip body fat off of them getting your
head cold is fantastic for the
blood-brain barrier it's something I try
to do each day some kind of a cold
shower or cold contrast the next is to
breathe there's a lot of different ways
that you can breathe but there's a
fantastic form of breathing called
Buteyko breathing so in an ideal
scenario you teach your body how to both
increase carbon dioxide and increase
oxygen simultaneously the form of
breathing that teaches you how to do
this is called Buteyko breathing and the
way to figure out if you're getting good
at it is you take a normal exhale and
then you just go for as long as you can
without taking a sharp inhale now a good
score would be anything about 40 seconds
or longer being able to hold your breath
after a passive exhale that's a good
sign that you can tolerate high levels
of co2 and high levels of oxygen so
maintenance of both carbon dioxide and
oxygen and not trying to breathe off all
your co2 all the time is actually
important for longevity okay next is to
upgrade your head I use light for this
there's a few different ways that I use
light I was talking last night to a few
people about Sun gazing and this is how
I do it I don't actually believe in the
Sun so I just put glasses on I'm stuck
indoors a lot of time riding so this is
actually fantastic for regulating your
circadian rhythm and getting a lot of
the benefits of sunlight it's a greenish
blue light wave spectrum and these are
glasses that you wear I wear these for
about 25 minutes every morning while I'm
working on my computer walking around
the house making a cup of coffee taking
a dump with my giant glasses on but
basically this spectrum is fantastic for
enhancing your wakefulness
greenish-blue spectrum of light okay the
next is deep sleep which is fantastic
for the mind a few of the things that I
found to really enhance deep sleep
exposure to red light at night expose
you to red light at night is one very
good way to enhance deep sleep so what
I've done is I've changed up
light bulbs in my bedroom and in my
office when I'm working at night to be
red light only red light only no
artificial light very small amounts of
blue light so for the fat burning
machine piece very simple I'm gonna give
you my 1 2 3 method for losing fat very
very quickly and I do this every single
day you get up in the morning and you're
in a fasted state preferably you fasted
for 12 to 16 hours 12 to 16 hours it's
kind of the magic window to go without
eating each day next when you're in that
fasted state you do anywhere from about
20 to 30 minutes of any type of aerobic
exercise not Portus all stress producing
exercise something very easy walk in the
sunshine easy swim easy yoga session two
to five minutes of cold exposure so your
fasted you wake up aerobic exercise and
you finish with cold and for a bonus on
that if you can have a little bit of
caffeine to enhance your fatty acid
utilization coffee or green tea it'll
blow up that effect even more and it
works like gangbusters especially if
you're trying to lose weight or tap into
your own adipose tissue next is to not
worry so much about diets this is my son
with a whole bunch of donuts that he
baked now there are certain people in
the world who based on their bacterial
ratio what's called their firma site to
bacteria ratio in their gut will respond
without a very high blood glucose
response to donuts and then other
people's blood glucose will go through
the roof and this is because there's a
lot of genetic variety when it comes to
the way you process sugars the way you
process fats the way you process
proteins so the idea is that you want to
figure out what diet actually works best
for you one of the best ways to start
into that is to do something into what
genes you actually possess that will
affect everything from how quickly you
metabolize caffeine to how much of an
inflammatory response you would have to
something like a ketotic based diet so
there's a lot of testing that you can do
but it's not my opinion that everyone
should follow a certain diet because we
live in a day and age where you can test
and you can figure out what diet is
worse or better for you recover like
Wolverine using better
living through science there are a lot
of different ways that you can recover
more quickly peptides are one there are
peptides called B PC 157 and TB 500 in
the States right now you can just order
these off of like veterinary websites or
chemical websites and you can actually
inject these around the skin to enhance
your joints ability to heal now another
one is neural therapy this is a very
interesting form of injections that I
underwent at a naturopathic clinic in
Idaho but they inject procane and
vitamin b12 into different nerves and it
really enhances the body's ability to be
able to heal okay the next one is to
fortify your immune systems or am i use
colostrum a lot of times during the year
to enhance my immune system and enhance
the amount of growth factors I have
available to me that one's fantastic
colostrum is a very good supplement to
take especially if you have a stressed
gut or if you need a little pick-me-up
when it comes to your immune system the
next thing that you really want to focus
on for the immune system is low level
physical activity bouncing vibrating
moving all day long I actually keep a
mini trampoline a mini trampoline in my
office now fantastic for the lymph fluid
the next one is a special stretch that a
guy named dr. David Beck the inventor of
the BOSU ball taught me it's called the
coil I do this on airplanes I do it when
I'm working it's one of the best
full-body stretches you can do you put
one leg back behind you like this you
bend the other one and you reach over
your head like this but basically this
coil exercise is one that have been
doing a lot of fantastic exercise for
kind of keeping the body fully stretched
throughout the day adequate collagen
consumption is something that a lot of
people don't get enough of kind of like
creatine so getting 20 to 40 grams of
collagen whether from a supplement form
or from a bone broth form like a cup of
bone broth has about 8 to 10 grams of
collagen in it for example really really
good way to enhance the health of your
skin your bones your joints I've got a
lot of slides that I wanted to go into
on optimizing your spirit but I'm just
gonna fly through these and give you
guys a few things to think about ok
optimizing your spirit if you haven't
read the book the biology of belief
which goes into
how different frequencies different
emotions can actually affect different
cells and affect your actual genetic
expression read the book and get to know
the idea about different frequencies
eliciting different emotions and
different genetic responses the biology
of belief the next is gratitude I do a
gratitude practice every single morning
I write down one thing I'm grateful for
one truth that I discovered and one
person that I can help or pray for or
serve that day daily gratitude practice
fantastic way to enhance the health of
your spirit along with your body and
your mind sound healing this is a guy
named poem guy who does sound healing
sessions in Sedona using sound to
enhance not just your health but also
things like your like your sleep this is
a love tuner I've seen a few people
around here wearing the love tuner which
you can blow on it creates a 520 Hertz
frequency that can actually enhance your
ability to express the emotion of love
the next is love we know about love
family relationships as I mentioned
earlier being fantastic for longevity
the next one is to experience sex
because I'm on a time crunch all I'm
gonna do is recommend that if you're
able to get your hands on via Amazon or
whatever the January 2018 edition of
Men's Health magazine where I was sent
on a three-month quest to look into
everything that a man could do to
enhance his sexual performance read that
magazine because I take a deep dive into
both the spirituality of sex and also a
whole bunch of different bio hacks for
men and women to enhance sexual
performance but I want to finish with
this the number one thing that you can
do to not just live a long time but to
look good naked and to be happy forever
to keep yourself motivated to keep
yourself happy to keep yourself
connected many of us are very very
focused as I was for a very long time on
all these bio hacks to optimize the body
and optimize the brain well we've got
this dry shriveled up soul and spirit
inside of us and the number one thing
that I've found that has really helped
me tap into true happiness and true
longevity is to care for the one single
part of me that I believe is going to be
around for the rest of
my life so the idea here is that you
want to care for your soul you want to
care for your spirit and not just get so
caught up with the bio hacks and the
six-pack abs and the optimization of
your neurotransmitters that you forget
to care about your happiness and your
purpose and true meaning in life and one
of the best ways that I found to do that
is by simply being quiet for a couple of
minutes you can try this now you can
close your eyes just block off all this
external stimuli just for a moment close
your eyes and connect with your purpose
connect with your soul and if you don't
know what your purpose is if you're
still seeking that out then finding that
purpose is one of the best things that
you can do for your longevity and for
your happiness mine is to empower people
to live a more adventurous joyful and
fulfilling life but if I can wake up
each morning feed my soul with that so
knowing your purpose knowing your
purpose is what feeds your soul so if
you aren't able to write your purpose
down I would challenge you at some point
today go to a quiet place and begin to
think about why it is that you're here
who it is that you can help here the
unique talents and the unique gifts that
you bring to the world because if you
don't do anything else finding your
purpose in life and then loving others
with that purpose is one of the most
powerful things that you can do for your
longevity and for your happiness
now you've been working with teaching
people how to heal themselves with their
minds right overcome disease overcome
any type of chronic illness or pain
through the mind the present of the mind
I grew up in a religion called Christian
Science that did not use medicine I
didn't get vaccinations when I was a kid
my dad wouldn't let me go to the
hospital he wanted to use thought where
the mindset to overcome any pain or any
physical ailment and so it's something
that I was learning in a different way
as an early kid mm-hmm when did you
start to learn about this philosophy or
principle or truth and start applying
into your life well I got run over by a
truck and a triathlon in 1986 on a
biking portion of the race I broke six
vertebrae in my spine and I was told
that I'd never walk again anyway I
decided against the surgery and I
thought what was that I'm not going
anywhere I'm not doing anything I'm
basically laying facedown and I thought
well there's an intelligence that's
giving us life that's keeping the heart
beating and digesting our food it really
knows how to heal way better than me and
the other thing I said is I'm not gonna
let me thought slipped by my awareness
that I don't want to experience now that
sounds really easy right but when you're
faced with crisis or trauma we tend to
focus on what we don't want to have
happen instead of what we do haven't I
want to have happened so I started on
this journey I decided against the
surgery and it was a big revolution at
the time and I went through six and a
half weeks of hell I just could not get
my mind to do what I wanted to do
because I'd start reconstructing my
vertebra and imaging an outcome and then
I start thinking I'm gonna be living in
a wheelchair why I sell my practice we
were thinking about the way you wanted
your body to look and feel in your mind
i reconstructed every single in the
morontia in my mind I wanted to show it
exactly three dimensionally because this
intelligence is always present right so
we got to be present with it so I'd
start off reconstructing my spine and
then I'd be like oh gosh um should I
sell my practice what if I live in
practice chiropractic yeah Southern
California Hawaii so I couldn't get my
mind to do what I wanted to do and then
after six weeks I just went through the
whole thing I felt like I hit a golf
ball right in the sweet spot something
clicked and from that point forward what
took me two and a half or three hours to
do I was able to do it in 45 minutes
that was firing and wiring you know
these new circuits and I was practicing
paying attention and then all of a
sudden I started noticing dramatic
changes in my health like this and the
moment I started noticing changes in my
body what was going on outside of me I
started correlating at what I was doing
inside of me now I was just hooked and I
just started doing with more passion and
more sincerity anyway back on my feet in
ten and a half weeks back training in
twelve weeks back in my clinic and and I
just made a deal with myself that if I
was ever able to walk again I'd spend
the rest of my life studying the
mind-body connection and mind over
matter and then I asked the fundamental
question has anybody else done it so
then I traveled to 17 different
countries and interviewed hundreds and
hundreds of people with serious health
conditions that were treating either
conventionally or unconventionally and
they were staying the same we're getting
worse and all of a sudden I got better
so what was the cause that produced the
effect you know is and what I learned
was so amazing I went back to school and
studied neuroscience because mind was
such a strong element it wasn't diet it
wasn't celibacy it wasn't any of those
things it was just really this element
and so then I was able to figure out
that there were four common things so
then I started seeing okay let's see if
we can teach this be able to reproduce
the outcome because that's science right
so we went through about what were the
four common things the first one was
that there they all believed and
accepted that there was an intelligence
that lived within them that was giving
them life these people you interviewed
who had had injuries that overcame no no
these are people with cancer ms lupus
Parkinson's disease got better yeah just
spontaneously it's called a spontaneous
majority so I was they believe there was
an intelligence there was some invisible
life force that was they were connected
to that they felt like they had lost
their connection to they became separate
and disconnected from and so they
developed the relationship with it
like you develop a relationship with
anybody it takes time
you got to be present you got to connect
you know to experience so that was the
first thing the second thing was that
they realized that it was the
mismanagement of their emotions and the
hormones of stress that really began to
create their condition so these people
realize that oh my god um i-i've been
mismanaging my attention and energy and
I got a I got to get beyond my past I
got to get beyond these emotions I got
to make some big changes I got to break
the habit of being myself you know I
stopped being this person now that
sounds really good theoretically and
philosophically but change is such a
hard thing right because the moment you
come back to your senses and you step
back into your life and you see that
person or you go to that place or you're
with that experience so many people are
unconsciously reacting in their thoughts
and feelings to everything in their
environment so now their environment is
controlling how they think and feel so
they realize that in order to change
their changing right they got to be
greater than their own fire mm greater
than the conditions in the world great
in the circumstances mindful that every
time they come right I'm not clear we
are all right I'm not gonna go back I'm
not gonna go back because the moment you
start reacting emotionally emotions are
a record of the past and if those
emotions are driving your thoughts
you're thinking in the past and if you
can't think greater than how you feel
and you believe your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny you're
creating more of your past right so the
hormones of stress push the genetic
buttons that create disease if you can
turn on the stress response just by
thought alone your thoughts gonna make
you sick and if your thoughts could make
you sick is it possible that your
thoughts could make you well so maybe
under realized that oh my god the
repetition of thinking and feeling and
the feeling of thinking caused me to
feel guilt and I don't even know what
skill that just feels like me it's just
I'm used to the same chemical continuity
now the moment they decided to change
anytime you decide to change and change
anything about yourself get ready
because it's going to feel uncomfortable
all right we're gonna leave the numb
yeah gonna leave the familiar and you
guys step into the unknown even if the
familiar is uncomfortable
painful right you still gonna be painful
leaving the pain right because some
people are super happy being unhappy
right so then they would rather cling to
their suffering than take a chance in
possibility so these people said I
really have nothing to lose right so
then they said I'm willing to be
uncomfortable in being the unknown and
it turns out that's the perfect place to
create from so the third thing they said
was okay so now that I know that I got a
break the haven't being myself and I
can't mismanage my thoughts and feelings
I got to change how I act I gonna watch
how I speak I got become conscious of
how unconscious I am because 95% of who
we are by the time we're thirty-five
years old
it's a set of memorize behaviors like a
computer program emotional reactions
unconscious beliefs and perceptions so
the first step to change is to become
conscious of how you think to notice how
you act to pay attention to how you feel
and the act of observing those states of
mind and body separates you from that
program know your your your the
consciousness observing their
programming so then they started
thinking how would I have to be in a new
life if I was really going to heal what
would I have to change about myself now
there's this interesting phenomenon that
if you close your eyes and you begin to
think about doing something you're an
athlete you understand this if your
background in football and you are
running a pattern or you are doing
something you would rehearse it in your
mind turns out that the act of mentally
rehearsing something when you're truly
present your brain does not know the
difference between what's going on out
there and what's going on in here in
fact your brain will begin to look like
you've been doing it for the last five
days and you've never run the course so
now your brain is no longer a record of
the past because typically it is now
it's a map to the future so now you're
priming your brain so that became a very
platform you know experiments with piano
players you know you can take a group of
people that never played the piano
before you divide them into two
different categories I think one group
of people you teach them one-handed
scales and chords you do a brain scan on
them they come and practice for two
hours a day for five days
at the end of five days if you rescan
the brain they produce circuits on the
opposite side of the brain nothing
magical there you learn something new
learnings making new connections get
some instruction you get instruction and
get your body involved get your body
involved you're gonna have an experience
experience in which is the brain pay
attention to what you're doing you got
to pay attention and repeat it firing
and wiring into a simple new circuits
you can take the other group of people
have them come for two hours a day for
five days to a brain scan before the
brain scan after have them close their
eyes and mentally rehearse playing those
scales and chords at the end of five
days they'll grow the same amount of
circuits and the brain as the people who
actually physically demonstrated the
action what does that mean it means not
only they change their brain by thinking
differently but their brain looks like
they've been playing the piano for five
days now set them in front of a piano
never played the piano before they'll
play those scales in courts because
their brain is wired to play it so now
the act of rehearsing who they're gonna
be what are the qualities and beginning
to get in this creative state began to
lay down the circuits of a new
personality and a new personality is
connected to a new personal reality so
the next question is does that change
the body so these people began to
reprogram their brain and body and all
of a sudden they began to act
differently why because they install the
circuits they begin to think differently
of course they began to feel differently
they they were no longer feeling pain
they're actually liking themselves right
so that if they're living by a different
emotion and they're they're feeling an
elevated emotion before they're healing
before they were healed they're not
waiting for their healing to feel joy
and gratitude they're feeling gratitude
and joy now their body is believing that
it's healed because the body's feeling
the emotion ahead of the experience and
if the environment signals the gene and
the end product of an experience in the
environment is emotion you're signaling
the gene ahead of the environment and
what a genes do genes make proteins or
where a protein is responsible the
structure and function of the body now
you're literally becoming somebody else
and now you're turning down the genes
for disease and you're turning up these
other genes so so you can't who is a
foreign who's enough for me yes so so we
what I found is that when I started
studying spontaneous remissions it was
for people who had reached the end of
their
belief where there was no longer any
answers they had the doctors gave up on
it nothing else to do right and so they
change everything about themselves and
you some of them were physicians you
know it's just going like wow well I
what if I what have I been doing
but now fast forward to today I mean in
an age of information ignorance is a
choice I mean you've got so much
information you need a doctor you don't
need a teacher you don't have priests
the Minister to gain information you
don't need an authority right you can
technology gives us the very quick
information so now people are informed
20 years ago doctor said do you have
this health condition and braved it yeah
and not only that you signed on without
a line you got the treatment in the
surgery fast forward to today everybody
just kind of goes wait a sec multiple
opinion yeah let me go home and you
research it and you say I want to try
this so now that some people are taking
their power back so so people are more
informed so surgical procedures
pharmaceuticals are not always the first
choice for people because there's other
ways and people only do the best with
what's available there are people that
are saying if I'm headed for genetic
destiny because my mother had this
health condition my father did this and
I know the gene doesn't create it but
how I act and how I feel is going to
signal the same gene well I'm gonna just
change my genetic future so now people
are super proactive in the process right
so that's point number one but point
number two is that if you if you start
realizing that this is actually possible
we in our last event two people with
stage four cancer completely reversed a
woman with a very serious neurological
disorder that even they couldn't even
name it crutches the whole bit left the
event no crutches well how does she do
that
mmm well let me ask you a question if
she doesn't look like a movie star and
she's not buffed and young and
attractive and successful she was like a
normal person and you listen to this
person's story and there's a thousand
people listening that story you're gonna
scratch your head and say wow if she can
do it so can i and just like you know
infection spreads amongst a community
that creates disease health and wellness
can be as infectious as disease right
and if the more you understand what
you're doing and why the how it gets
easier and if nothing's left the
conjecture superstition or dogma or
spiritual New Age stuff but
it's grounded in science you're gonna
have more intention behind what you're
doing and you're gonna assign more
meanings more believable exactly I'm
just blind faith yes it no it please
backing you're right and then if we can
set up the conditions in the environment
and give people the proper instruction
you know those people that get their
behaviors to match their intentions and
their actions equal to their thoughts
I think the mind and body working
together they're gonna have a new
experience and that experience then is
going to enrich even more circuits in
the brain the end product of an
experience is an emotion also and
they're gonna feel unlimited they're
gonna feel in power they're gonna feel
successful they're gonna feel worthy now
they're teaching their body chemically
to understand what their mind is
intellectually and there's no knowledge
as for the mind what experiences for the
body and they're embodying that
information but isn't it amazing that
some of these churches when people get
to believe whether they have science
backing it or not they just it's the
belief they step out into the unknown
step out of your body
and hear something's right
instantaneously instantaneously and we
do see that a lot in some people like oh
that's yeah can that be possible how can
it be possible what we we've I haven't
researched now I assembled a team of
scientists we've done 8,500 brain scans
in fact I was just showing my research
to a group of researchers and Santa Cruz
this past week and they were blown away
and I said now watch this person this
person is going to have a
transformational moment they said how do
you know I buy I've seen enough of these
in the next moment the whole brain just
lights up that person is switched on
they'll never be the same person again
they're having a transcendental moment
here you're sharing in the world it
could carry the thought of your healing
why because it's consistent with the
energy guilt isn't gonna carry the
thought of your healing it's a different
frequency and all of a sudden now the
person is elevating their emotional
state and they're allowing their thought
to be carried on their frequency they're
broadcasting a whole new energetic
signature but thoughts are the language
of the brain and feelings of the
language of the body and how you think
and how you feel creates your state of
being so then the question is if you
keep practicing creating that state of
being it should become familiar to you
yes or no the word meditation literally
means to become familiar with so then if
you're practicing moving into these
elevated states and your heart is
coherent and we're measuring and I can
say Lois you got it now do it for 30
minutes now do it for 60 minutes and you
practice creating that coherence you'll
know when you're there and when you're
not yes or no and then you would be able
to say like a skill like anything else
give me a minute I'm gonna step out and
you're gonna go back in the heart
coherence and bring up that state you
listen I now know I mean we've measured
genetic changes hormonal changes
neurotransmitter changes we've measured
immune system responses by trading fear
for gratitude we've measured gene
expressions we now know that people can
signal the gene to zero for kick to
reduce cancer and tumors signal the gene
to grow new neurons we've measured this
signal the gene for for stem cells will
go to damaged tissues and repair them
oxidative stress gene signal we've we've
seen that in art and our students now
here's the deal after all of those
studies in the last six years you can't
tell me you're too old to do this work
can't sound with them
we got people in their 80s doing
miraculous things you can't tell me
you're too sick to do this work the
people that work the end of their life
Stage four and we turn that battleship
around well you can't tell me that you
had to turbulent of a past to do this
where were people that were really rough
paths that are now free you can't tell
me you're not you've never meditated for
where people have never meditated before
the most profound mystical experience
you can't tell me you're too overweight
to under wait to add a shape to in shape
you can't tell me that anywhere because
all colors all races everybody can do it
that's the cool part about it and when
you get a community of people together
and you move them from one state of mind
to another there's this moment and I can
almost predict when it happens the
second or third day where people just
start hooking up and then when they
start hooking up you know we start we're
seeing now in our events I mean a lady
that was blind from birth
5% vision but the only event was seen I
mean how do you explain that we had
three people in the last two events that
were deaf their hearing now people with
crutches that were limited or walking
without crutches and canes
spinal cord injuries I mean Parkinson's
disease in a week
like that's gotta be like if that's it
doesn't wake you up to what's possible
and you're witnessing a tumor on a
woman's thyroid that was there at the
beginning the event that's gone at the
end of the event I mean you you got to
scratch your head and just go wrong the
reality isn't at all the way I think it
is and some people go to the healing
they get in the cage for their knee
problems and they come out hearing
better that just happened to a cot the
other day he had a bad knees and he was
he went in to get his knees healed but
he forgot that he's you know he didn't
think about his hearing problem he got
bit by a poisonous snake when he was
like a three-year-old kid and we said
hearing problems where his hearing aids
the whole bit comes out of them he said
he'd never felt in that amount of love
in his entire life and that's the common
thing that people say the woman that got
her vision back that's not what she
talked about she didn't talk about the
fact that she could see all she kept
saying was I feel like a child again I
feel like a baby again I feel fresh I
feel like I'm newborn I feel clean
because you kept talking about how she
felt then she said oh yeah and I could
see faces now and there were these two
big flower arrangements on the stage and
she said I thought those were guards
guarding dr. Joe the whole week
she couldn't even see the flower she
just saw the you know the form would you
like to see the flowers now but but the
first thing was how they felt and he the
same way he said I had never I was
sobbing I never felt so much love in my
life it wasn't like I was trying to feel
it it just happened and he said and I
got up and all of a sudden I could hear
dr. Joe talking without my hearing aids
now just kind of like I think my knees
were a little better okay what my hear
you rather you know so you never know
right
you never know everyone's got to get in
the cage who's been your greatest
teacher who life no doubt about it I
believe that life is our initiation I
mean I do my best to see my life as a
reflection of my mind and I think that
and I think that life is our greatest
teacher reflection of your mind is
essentially like what you've created is
a reflection of how you've been
yeah exactly so for showing up sick
physically then that's what you've
created here but I don't believe that
germs make me sick I believe I make me
sick I do I mean there's no germs with
my name on it out there I mean they're
called opportunistic bacteria because
they're waiting for an opportunity for
your immune system remised
when I was 39 years old
I was diagnosed with a kind of unusual
arrhythmia where the left side and right
side of my heart was beating out of
synch and I was 330 pounds and I was the
average American and I was eating and
eating and eating and I wasn't active I
was running a business that didn't
require me to be active I sat at a desk
all day long and I just turned into this
sick human being every cell in your body
turns over anywhere from 6 weeks to 6
months how do I best put myself in a
position for those new cells to be
healthy as opposed to the sick ones that
are in my heart and so I started
weightlifting and as I lost weight I got
better I ended up not needing the
medications and I discovered that Wow
like you don't have to get sick and if
you get sick you can actually do things
to fix yourself this was a novel idea I
thought you know only doctors could do
that for you in hospitals and stuff like
that when my doctor told me something I
thought mmm I don't know if that's true
I think I want to go find out so just
that nuance that I didn't take what the
authority said to me as gospel and
followed it is is is probably a hallmark
of baby boomers I also felt like I was
very depressed I wouldn't want it I
wasn't ready to die I wasn't willing to
accept go quietly oh this is part of
Aging I was like no it's not part of my
aging and this isn't how I end my story
and so I think that those two things
combined gave me the courage to seek
other information but then I had to sort
through the information and pick what
was good and what was it I apply
critical thinking first and the first
element of my critical thinking is
evolution so
so we don't pay attention to 1.8 million
years of the selection pressure that
molded us into what we are today but we
put all of our faith in science du jour
so the first thing I do is I look at
things and say why would evolution have
endowed us with that we have one job and
that is to keep proliferation of the
species that's it we talk about
reproductive fitness reproductive
Fitness holds you together and well
until you pass the reproductive ages
then you fall apart because you should
have done your job by then so I apply
evolutionary edicts to everything that I
look at and I go does this hold true
would evolution have endowed us with
this and if I can't answer that question
without saying yeah I can see why this
would be a value to us then I
immediately discount when I look at
these things I look at them from
evolution I'd say okay when would
ketosis have really come ok famine it
would have got us through the famine
would it because we're metabolically
flexible I look at everything that way
first why is this important why would we
be endowed with it where did it come
from
and then I do my research from there
that's really really interesting I think
that's super smart all right so you
start with that evolutionary lens I
think that's insanely powerful as a
backstop of does this make sense then
what do you do the next thing is that
you cannot have an agenda when you're
reading research many people whether
they realize it or not are coming to
find something to support their opinion
and you can't have an agenda you have to
accept the good with the bed because if
you're truly in search of the truth an
agenda could skew the way you look at
things so I would say the most powerful
thing that you could have when you're
doing research of this type is not to
come with an agenda or if you do have an
agenda acknowledge it so that you can
then discount it when you feel giddy
about filing this study all like let me
see if I can find the study that contra
byxis and be open to the fact that you
want the truth you don't want to be
right I say don't listen to me or
somebody else I say that you have to
make the decision for you we're all very
unique because of our individual
evolutionary journeys and so where
somebody can eat a food that they thrive
on maybe I can't information is
overwhelming today and people don't know
what to do and they actually become numb
after a while like I can't eat this I
can't eat that like what the hell can I
do I say to people go back a few hundred
years where did your people come from
what foods were indigenously available
and and during what seasons and start
there to build your foundation of what
you do well with but I think that the
reality is that you can't just take
anything anyone says and hit your wagon
to it you've got to you've got to let it
ruminate in your head and you've got to
think about it and you've got to keep
challenging it because there's so much
information out there today and so much
of it is wrong it's scary I mean I fall
prey to this when I'm reading studies
and I think to myself this just doesn't
sound right like I I need to dig deeper
and then I find out oh I can see why
they have this opinion people are
protecting their own little fiefdom
by you know sticking to their to their
guns when they really should change
their opinion and move forward like if I
eat a lot of fiber I wake up in the
morning with brain fog really yeah
because because fiber is supposed to be
fermented in the large intestine right
yeah if the fiber is is being fermented
in the small intestine then you're
getting bloated after a meal because
it's fermenting here and not down there
you're not farting it out you're burping
it back on right that's the first sign
that you've got microbes and and stuff
inside your small intestine when you
start to to see these foods making you
feel that way it's time for you to say
stop my mother you
to say if you lost don't run because you
could be running in the wrong direction
because I'm so terrified of antibiotics
I will tell you because I think that's
almost certainly what caused Lisa's
problem so walk me through non
antibiotic things to try from a
supplement standpoint grape fruit seed
extract there's a free fatty acid and
I'm gonna get the name wrong but it's
thoughts with the you it's like it's
like you cyclic acid they they permeate
the microbes cell wall they make it
burst the other thing is like coconut
oil I know everybody's like Oh coconut
I'm not seeing pounded down but on an
empty stomach first thing in the morning
a teaspoon full of coconut oil because
coconut oil helps to destroy those
microbes the reason the small intestine
becomes inhabited in the first place is
because the acid level in your stomach
is becoming too neutral we need to drop
the PA to make it more acidic because if
the acidity in the small intestine was
appropriate they would never live there
they would only live when they got to
the large intestine so clearly you have
an issue with your small intestine and
the acidity level so by you know a lot
of people will say I got better when I
started taking apple cider vinegar three
times yeah because that apple cider
vinegar is washing down into the small
intestine 8 it's killing that bacteria
that shouldn't be there in the first
place resting alright on a totally
different topic talk to me about your
routines I know that you use a lot of
supplementation you're very vocal about
the things that you've used or tried
what are some things that are just an
absolute standard part of your day I
have the 3 s's the most important
evolutionary edicts that if you practice
these regularly you will live a long
healthy life and there the 3 s's Sun sex
and sleep okay the Sun will make you
want to have more sex the Sun will
improve the quality of your sleep if
you'll get out there getting Sun all day
long if you do those three things
regularly you will live longer you won't
get prostate cancer there's evidence
that women who have
more often and their partner actually
ejaculates in them don't get fibroids
they don't get uterine cancer I mean
guys who have more more orgasms or
protected against prostate cancer when
you when you do the things that
evolution put you here to do which is in
the Sun have sex and sleep well you
that's 90 percent of the job right there
I used Milano 10 to 25 micrograms a day
because the what we attribute the Sun to
doing for us is vitamin D all vitamin D
vitamin D so they get that because of
epidemiological studies show that people
who live closer to the equator don't get
heart disease they don't get this they
don't get cancer don't get it so we just
say oh it's the Sun it's vitamin D but a
lot of research has led us down it's
like vitamin D doesn't play out when you
supplement it it doesn't seem to confer
those same benefits well the most
overlooked thing about your skin is
something called the Milano Courtin
system it produces five different
hormones and every cell in your body has
a Milano court and receptor on it and
the Milano court system is responsible
for libido that's a big one because
anything that improves libido you're
getting healthier because that's that's
evolutionary edict number one have lots
of sex and lots of children before you
die and the really the rest of it is
diet and sleep it really is I do
everything I can to protect and improve
the quality of my sleep and I'm I'm
almost militant about my diet but I come
to the conclusion that in order to be
healthy today you almost have to be
militant about it because there's so
many people pulling on you oh come on
come on you can have pizza come on you
can go out and have a few drinks come on
and I almost think that they want me to
do it not because they think I'm missing
out but then it kind of makes them feel
less guilty for what they're dead of
course you know sex is really big I know
it sounds corny but it's the
evolutionary edict it's the one reason
you're on this planet and the more you
do it the more your body
we'll reward you the 3 s's son sex and
sleep in the mind really heal the body
and if so is there any scientific
evidence to convince sceptical
physicians like me these are the
questions that fuel the last few years
of my research and what I discovered is
that the scientific community the
medical establishment has been proving
for over 50 years that the mind can heal
the body we call it the placebo effect
and we've been trying to outsmart it for
decades the placebo effect is a thorn in
the side of the medical establishment
it's an inconvenient truth that gets in
between trying to bring new treatments
new surgeries into the medical
establishment so it's it's a problem
supposedly but I actually think this is
really good news the placebo effect is
excellent news because it's concrete
evidence that the body holds within it
and Nate self repair mechanisms that
that can make unthinkable things happen
to the body so if you find this
surprising if you have a hard time
believing that the body can heal itself
you need look no further than the
spontaneous remission project a database
compiled by the Institute of noetic
Sciences of over 3,500 case studies in
the medical literature of patients who
have gotten better from seemingly
incurable illnesses you think there's
such a thing as an incurable illness I I
swear if you go look at this database
it's it'll blow your mind everything's
in there Stage four cancers that
disappeared without treatment
hiv-positive patients that became HIV
negative heart disease kidney failure
diabetes high blood pressure thyroid
disease autoimmune diseases gone a great
example of this in the case in the
medical literature is a case study from
nineteen
57 of mr. right who had advanced
lymphocercoma so things weren't going
well for mr. right time was really
running out he had tumors the size of
oranges and his armpits his neck his
chest his abdomen his liver and his
spleen were enlarged and his lungs were
filling up with two quarts of Milky
fluid every day that had to be drained
in order for him to breathe but mr.
right wasn't giving up hope he had heard
about this wonder drug called krebiozen
and he was begging his doctor come on
just give me some of that krebiozen it's
all gonna be good now unfortunately the
krebiozen was only available on a
research protocol and the protocol
required that the doctor be able to make
an assessment that says that this guy
has at least three months to live and
his doctor dr. West just couldn't do
that but mr. right was tenacious and he
didn't give up he kept badgering his
doctor until finally his doctor was like
okay fine I'll give you the creb Yuson
so he dosed him up on a Friday not
expecting that mr. right would make it
through the weekend but to his utter
shock when dr. West came in to do rounds
on Monday mr. right was up walking
around the woods and his tumors had
shrunk to half their original size they
had melted like snowballs on a hot stove
and ten days after getting the kreb
years and they were gone so mr. Wright
was up rockin and rollin like praise and
krebiozen as the miracle drug he
believed it to be for two months until
the initial reports came out about Krebs
and that said that it didn't really look
like krebiozen was working so well and
mr. Wright fell into a deep depression
and his cancer came back so this time
dr. West decided to get sneaky and he's
he told his patient that you know that
crabby ISM that you got that was a
tainted version really not so good but I
got us some ultra pure highly
concentrated CREB use and this stuff's
got it going on he then injected mr.
Wright with nothing but distilled water
and once again the tumors disappeared
the fluid in his lungs went away mr.
Wright was up rockin and rollin for
another two months and then the American
Medical Association blew it by
publishing a nationwide study that
proved definitively krebiozen was
worthless
two days later mr. Wright after hearing
this news died soon after that I came
across another study in the medical
literature that was the stuff of fairy
tales
three baby girls were born delivered by
midwife on Friday the 13th in the
Okefenokee Swamp near the Georgia
Florida border and the Midwife
pronounced that these three babies born
on such a fateful day were all hexed but
first she said would die before her 16th
birthday the second before her 21st the
third before her 23rd birthday and as it
turned out the first girl died the day
before her 16th birthday
the second died the day before her 21st
birthday and the third girl who knew
what had happened to the other two not
when to that on the day before 23rd
birthday she showed up at the hospital
hyperventilating begging them to make
sure she survived she wound up dying
that night these two case studies are
great examples from the medical
literature of the placebo effect and its
opposite the nocebo effect so mr. right
when he got that distilled water and his
tumors melted away that's a great
example of the placebo effect when you
get a seemingly inert treatment and yet
something's happening physiologically in
the body such that disease goes away the
nocebo effect is the opposite so the
three hexed girls are an example of the
nocebo effect when the minds belief that
something bad is going to happen in the
body then comes to manifest so the
scientific literature the medical
journals like the New England Journal of
Medicine and the Journal of the American
Medical Association these scientific
journals are full of evidence that the
placebo effect in the nocebo effect are
incredibly powerful we've known this
since the 1950s and we've seen countless
case studies that show that in almost
everything you study if you give people
a fake treatment a sugar pill a saline
injection or most effectively a fake
surgery 18 yet really 18 to 80 percent
of the time people get better and it's
not just in their mind that's what I
thought in the beginning like oh they're
just feeling better than thinking better
but it's not it's actually in their
physiology this is measurable you can
actually see what happens to the body so
for example patients getting placebos
were found to have ulcers that healed
colons that became less inflamed bronchi
that dilated warts that disappeared
cells looked different under the
so it's provable it's happening in the
body even though it's initiated by the
mind so when you when you look at these
it's some of the studies are just
amazing I love the Rogaine study so you
know you get a bunch of bald men you
give them placebos they grow hair the
opposite is also true so if you give
people a placebo and you tell them it's
chemotherapy they vomit and they lose
their hair so this is really happening
in the body and the question that I had
is is it just the mines positive belief
that's making this happen not according
to Harvard recent research or Ted Kap
checked according to him he thinks that
that the most essential part is actually
the nurturing care of a health care
provider more so even than the minds
positive belief that some of the studies
actually say the doctor is the placebo
what can be so Ted Kaptchuk wanted to
study this and you did a great study
looking at patients that were getting
placebos for an illness for treatment of
an illness and he told them you're
getting a placebo there's nothing in
here and inert ingredients nothing
active they still got better
most likely captrick postulated because
they felt tended nurtured they felt like
they were doing something you felt like
somebody cared so to say that you can
heal yourself is sort of a misnomer
you know the body can heal itself the
body has these innate natural
self-repair mechanisms but the
scientific data proves that you need the
attending nurturing care of a health
care provider of some sort of a healer
to facilitate that process it's not an
easy process to go through alone so it
makes a big difference if somebody else
is holding that positive belief with you
but the problem is while the doctor can
be the placebo the doctor can also be
the nocebo so what patients need from us
as health care providers they need us to
be forces of healing not forces of fear
or pessimism so every time your doctor
tells you you have an incurable illness
you're gonna have to take that that
medication for the rest of your life or
god forbid you get cancer and they say
you've got a 5% five-year survival rate
it's really
no different than when that Midwife told
those three baby girls that they were
hexed it's a form of medical hexing
that's so prevalent as doctors we think
we're being realistic you know we're
giving people the kind of information we
think they need to know but we actually
can be harming them instead we need to
be more like dr. West you know taking
that distilled water really mr. right I
promise this is gonna do it for you but
do we have to count on our doctors to
dupe us you know do we have to get fake
surgeries and fake drugs and wind up in
clinical trials this is what led the
next phase of my research so in my last
TEDx talk I talked about a new wellness
model that I developed called the whole
healthcare and this came about as part
of my research trying to find how else
can we harness this minds power that's
clearly evidenced by the placebo effect
than the nocebo effect can we do
something without being in a clinical
trial and my hypothesis was that in
order to heal ourselves in order to be
optimally healthy we need more than just
a good diet a regular exercise program
getting enough sleep taking your
vitamins following your doctor's orders
those things are all great and critical
important but I also came to believe
that we need healthy relationships a
healthy professional life a healthy
creative life a healthy spiritual life a
healthy sex life a healthy financial
life a healthy environment in essence we
need a healthy mind so I wanted to try
to prove this and I went into the
medical literature and the copious data
that I found proving that all of those
things are essential really blew my mind
they compiled them all into my upcoming
book mind over medicine scientific proof
you can heal yourself but I want to give
you a few highlights about what what
this is all about so you can see from
the whole health cairn that all of these
facets are built upon a foundation stone
that I call your inner pilot light and
for me that's that essential authentic
part of you that knows what's true for
you that's willing to tell you the truth
about maybe what's out of alignment in
your life what stones and your whole
health cairn might be out of balance and
as you see I've put the body physical
health on the top of the whole health
cairn because
the most fragile the most precarious and
the most easy to kind of fall out of
balance if other things in your life
aren't going so well so what I found in
the medical data is that relationships
matter people who have a strong social
network have half the rate of heart
disease compared to those who are lonely
married people are twice as likely to
live long lives than unmarried people in
fact curing your loneliness may be the
most important measure of prevention you
can enact upon your body moreso than
quitting smoking or starting to exercise
your spiritual life matters those who
attend religious services live up to 14
years longer your professional life
matters you really can work yourself to
death in Japan they call it Karoshi
death by overwork and people who survive
those the survivors of those who die of
Karoshi can actually apply for workman's
comp like benefits in Japan but it's not
just Japan it's actually happening even
more in the United States we just don't
get benefits here so they found they did
one study and they found that people who
fail to take their vacation they're
actually 1/3 more likely to get heart
disease attitude really matters happy
people lives 7 to 10 years longer than
unhappy people and optimists are 77%
less likely to get heart disease than
pessimists so how does this happen
what's happening in the brain that's
making the body change this was what was
fascinating to me what I found is that
the brain communicates with all the
cells in the body via hormones and
neurotransmitters so for example if you
have a negative thought belief or
feeling in the brain it's your brain
triggers this as a threat
something's wrong if you feel lonely or
pessimistic things are bad at work
you're in a toxic relationship the
amygdala says threat threat threat and
it turns on the hypothalamus the talks
to the pituitary gland that communicates
with the adrenal gland and the adrenal
gland starts spitting out stress
hormones like cortisol norepinephrine
epinephrine it turns on what Walter
Canon at Harvard called the stress
response that triggers the
parasympathetic excuse me the
sympathetic nervous system and puts you
into that fight-or-flight mode you know
which is adaptive it's protective if
you're running away from a mount
you know but in everyday life you're
supposed to have that quick stress
response if there's a threat and then
it's supposed to switch right off this
isn't what happens in our regular lives
these days unfortunately there's a
counterbalancing relaxation response
that Herbert Benson at Harvard described
and when this comes about the stress
response turns off the parasympathetic
nervous system turns on and healing
hormones like oxytocin dopamine nitric
oxide endorphins fill the body and bathe
every cell in the body what I found the
most amazing about this is that there's
natural self-repair mechanisms that we
all have
they only flip on when the nervous
system is relaxed so when you're having
stress responses the fat all those
natural self-repair mechanisms get
flipped off the body's too busy trying
to fight or flee in order to heal itself
so what when you think about this you
have to start to wonder like how can I
possibly start to change the balance in
my own body so one study showed that on
average we have more than 50 stress
responses per day and if you're lonely
or depressed or pessimistic or unhappy
at work or in a miserable relationship
that member is going to be more than
twice as many now this is the relaxation
response is what researchers think
explains the placebo effect so when
you're going to get supposedly maybe a
new wonder drug you don't know whether
you're getting the placebo or not it
triggers that relaxation response that
combination of the Rhines positive
belief and the nurturing care of a
healthcare provider relaxes the nervous
system and then all those natural
self-repair mechanisms can come into
play fortunately though you don't have
to be in a clinical trial to turn on
your relaxation responses there are lots
of simple pleasurable activities that
turn on the relaxation responses and
these have been proven in the medical
literature so you can meditate you can
express yourself creatively you can get
a massage do yoga or Tai Chi you can go
out with your friends you can do work
that you love you can have sex you can
laugh you can exercise you can play with
animals so I ask you to consider the
whole health cairn in your own life
which stones in your whole health
might be out of balance each of these
stones can be can be a factor for
creating stress responses or relaxation
responses how might you turn on more
relaxation responses in your body and
most importantly what does your body
need in order to heal what prescription
do you need to write for yourself and
are you gonna be brave enough to take
action on the truth of what your inner
pilot light already knows I believe our
system our health care system is badly
broken and it's largely because we've
lost respect for the body's ability to
heal itself the medical establishment
has gotten arrogant we've come to think
that with all of our modern technology
and all that we've learned in the past
century that we've mastered nature and
we find it repelling to think that maybe
nature could be better than we are
sometimes and yet spontaneous remissions
from incurable diseases are proof that
sometimes nature's just better than we
are
it's a narcissistic wound for physicians
we don't know what to do with that it
makes us feel helpless and hopeless and
useless but fortunately we're needed the
the physician and all the other health
care providers are absolutely essential
to this process we need to embrace this
and patients need to change their
outlooks on this as well it's not just
doctors we need patients to stop
thinking that your body is not your
business taking your power and handing
it over to other health care providers
your body is your business and your mind
has tremendous power to communicate with
your body such that your body can heal
itself
I just got a patient in last week that
it just wrenches your heart because when
when the doctors that you think that
they're in a position of authority they
were highly educated and they're working
on this concept of health this girl
comes in with stage zero cancer mm-hmm
Stacey Sarah stage zero okay so when you
look at this for one thing it's really
hard to categorize if stage zero is a
cancer or if it's just abnormal cell
growth or if it's spontaneous and
resolves on its own there there's
there's no actual data on what was her
history leading up to that a cancer that
got taken away and now she's at stage
zero
nope no how this is somebody who goes in
for a standard checkup they get the
mammogram which dramatizes the brush
tissue and radiates it in that you know
mammogram every year cuz you're over 40
and you know high stress you know
fibroid formation horrible died you know
she gets her flu shot every year so you
know she's following the medical model
right and so she does a mastectomy take
the heroic approach and they cut it off
okay and then they decide to do the
other breast as well so she had a double
mastectomy for something that would have
resolved on its own that wasn't even a
problem and it's it's just like oh my
god it was like getting gutshot you know
I love you I'm gonna do everything we
can to get your immune system strong and
healthy and I'm scared to death to tell
you that you and an [ __ ] for a doctor
yeah okay that they didn't do anything
to strengthen your immune system they
still have that victim mental status
right right that's why we got to do this
yeah you need to stop that ignorance you
know if you got stage breast cancer
stage stay to zero or stage one okay if
it's on the left side that's where the
little imp for the gut drain so you got
to look at gut issues so you do
everything you can to strengthen immune
says
then if it's on the right side that's
limped for the chest so everything you
can to strengthen the immune system but
look at the aggravating factors you you
get the immunes of the doctors focused
in that the body is smart self feeling
and self regulating and that a tumor in
the breast is not a tumor it's it's an
immune system response for a systemic
illness right breast cancer is not the
breast it's the system the entire system
and the lifestyle the whole thing so
that's that physical chemical and
emotional stressors yes because they're
on this delusionary mindset this victim
mindset of geez I got it because it's
bad luck or bad genes yeah and none of
that stuff's true yeah I got yet I mean
the genes of the Northern Europeans they
survived the Black Plague yeah okay the
genes of every other culture on the
planet survived
whatever cultural challenges they had
yeah you know and our genes are strong
and robust strong robust and adaptive
uh-huh got our species is found from the
Sahara to the Arctic yeah in and this is
what doctors really got to ask okay if
you're presenting with you know back
pain high blood pressure cholesterol
fibromyalgia chronic fatigue I mean why
doesn't the doctors sit down and talk to
this woman to develop a dialogue and say
you know you've got these lumps in this
left side what do you think caused it
and she was she was like taken aback
caused it what do you mean and I said
well this is the end result of physical
chemical or emotional stress this is a
weakened immune system this is the body
adapting to that kind of a lifestyle how
do you adapt it yeah and and so she says
well you know I just gotten divorced you
know and and I had a really horrible
lifestyle and you know this and this and
you know she had multiple courses of
antibiotics for urinary tract infections
no no we're talking like since she was a
kid no way okay so she used I think like
45 48 something like that and so and so
then you start to put together the
pattern so when you know every time you
get a course of antibiotics that's
generally a poisonous mold and they
could die
the system and so then you see this
pattern okay so did you have difficult
menstrual cycles when you're a teenager
oh man they were horrible
okay good did you have a pelvic trauma
so when you look at the pelvis has
housing half of this automatic nervous
system essential for the immune system
the parasympathetic okay did you have a
trauma when you were a kid yeah you know
right when she was ten so so you start
to put together a trauma weakened in the
immune system causing her body to go in
a fight-or-flight state having difficult
menstrual cycles weakening that tissue
and then instead of looking for somebody
looking for the problem they just gave
her antibiotics on top of antibiotic and
you know just said well you just got a
weakened immune system nobody taught her
about healthy food right you know she
pooped every other day not enough nuts I
mean it's like not enough yeah I mean so
she's got a TOC stick slow gastro alone
Tilly how do you think her sleep
patterns work well that's exacerbating
the whole lifestyle issue too right it's
it's also adaptation thinking think of
this if you've got this fight or flight
system because of a chronic bam trauma
when you were a kid your body's in this
constant fight or flight so if a leaf
falls whoa I'm gonna be right on it okay
so you can't sleep through the night so
you got interrupted sleep patterns okay
you got you know you're getting up to
pee or you're getting up because you're
sore none of that stuff's accurate okay
it means that you're in this hyper
excitable stress state yeah it's it's
really challenging for people because
they're just not taught we're not taught
about any of this in school and we don't
know like we just don't know but the
thing is is that there are answers out
there people do have been doing research
in this but you just you don't hear it
you don't know about it people aren't
talking about it on the news it's it's
not unless you do the research you know
you mean the stress levels won't show up
on a blood test and you see that but
most cancers spontaneously resolve and
they don't know why why because the
immune system you know
they say we're in our lifetime the
average person goes through three bouts
of cancer but without even knowing it so
and that's like what you're saying it's
like it happens in the background your
immune system takes care of it
you you quit your job and there's a
little bit less stress for a while so
your body gets on top of it you know
domain and so but three times during a
life and you don't even know it which is
interesting so if they had tested you
during that time you would have been in
the system and you would have been going
being sucked down the the whirlpool at
trying to fight the disease instead of
looking for the cause I mean the CDC
website actually says that the decline
massive decline of disease since 1900
was because of chlorinated water okay
because you're clean in the system they
also say 85% of all disease is from
stress so they've got that sighs so they
say that they say that 85% they say you
just settle down okay I know what you're
thinking that's because then you might
think they might expand on the physical
chemical and emotional stress so where
do they go from that they're the biggest
purchaser of vaccines in the mirror so
the way to fix that is through chemicals
right that makes sense you to get a
little actually say that I know but
there's got to be a chemical response
you know on your Facebook videos and in
your YouTube videos you talked a lot
about the three stressors physical
chemical and emotional stressors that
are wreaking havoc on people's immune
systems and as a result of that
cascading effects of disease and things
so with the physical or chemical and
emotional stress or is what are like the
top couple in each of those three
categories that your your ooh I gave a
key and this is fun too because if you
look at it the body really adapts to tow
stressors and that adaptation is as
misinterpreted this has a lack of ease
so like the physical stressors the two
most common sedentary lifestyle and
ridiculously hard working okay but with
an altered system here's here's a weird
one real quick I was at work yesterday
and my part-time job and one of the gals
there just had a baby four months ago
and she comes in wearing a half brace
thing I said what's up with your hand
did you have I said dude it was you have
carpal tunnel she goes no just gave me
this long rambling name of what her
doctor said it is it's from picking up
the baby in a new way and
said her pediatrician or whoever tells
her this is very common with like three
out of four new moms have this syndrome
I think that was something have you
heard of it
so she has to wear this thing and I said
how was she wearing that for it was a
really long name and they said it's
super common with new moms because
there's this this new you know they're
they're scooping up their kit and is
only on one hand with her and I said how
long you have to wear that brace she
goes oh probably a few months you know
and then um if it doesn't get better
then it's cortisone injections and then
if not that then they're gonna do
surgery I thought from picking up your
brand-new baby for forma that just blew
my mind and she's like yeah so hopefully
it doesn't go the surgery route these
are things that everyday people are just
like there's no clue I'm like this is
absolutely ridiculous to even hear those
words come out of your mouth yeah take a
chill pill just take deep breath in know
that the experts are not experts okay
and you know if you get a checker with a
repetitive motion how come not all the
checkers have it how come not all the
moms have it what slowed okay how come
she only has one sigh oh she only picks
up the baby and don't forget you got to
lift correctly don't lift and turn have
you heard that really okay you know you
get the Aboriginal guy that's picking up
the deer and throwing it on his shoulder
no clog don't lift that deer that way
yeah you could throw it disc come on our
species wouldn't have made it we are the
result of that wake okay
well even when you get a box delivered
you know it'll save it'll give you a
position oh yeah two people like make
sure you because we're all so weak I
mean you're right we wouldn't have made
it as a species if you were I mean they
were dragon pelts and skinny things and
I mean this is ridiculous crazy pick up
a baby well if you go against the
culture because that's the Church of
medicine yeah it's the church of
Pharmacology it's this this deity okay
that it's that you know the same medical
doctor is a medical deity okay the D but
you know they aren't knowledgeable they
have a tremendous amount of knowledge
yeah it is okay but not a lot of wisdom
mm-hmm okay they don't know how to do it
they're not looking at that the real
doctors the doctor within
okay your body is self-healing and self
regulating and if you respect those
bodily processes even though they seem
to present in a stage of pathology okay
like oh my god you got high blood
pressure
okay why you know are you dehydrated are
you not sleeping good are you in a
stress State all of those are
appropriate to develop high blood
pressure okay because you need that to
survive so it's never oh my gosh you
know you need this diuretic or beta
blocker yeah every time you take one
blood pressure drug your risk of stroke
increases 30% we said at a study out of
a University of Alabama Wow and they say
if you're on three blood pressure drugs
you're you're in worse shape than if you
had no medications whatsoever okay and
but again think of this psychotic and
fear you don't pick that thing up that
way you know repetitive motion oh my god
your blood pressure is bad you know
let's get to the medical deity quick
okay ya know instead of hey dude your
body is intelligent it's responded
within within a stress state with an
elevated blood pressure how much water
do you drink you know what's your sleep
patterns how much Sun you yeah how much
Sun yeah you know what you did do you
know what a plant is you can eat them
you know and your average person just
taking in the media to tell them to
chill it's like they it's not it's not
yeah yeah you don't understand my doctor
says this right right this one patient
and man he looks like a like a Greek god
75 years old built like a tank ten years
ago when he was 65 he had a high PSA or
prostate specific antigen test I think I
thought you talked about him before yeah
because it's so it's such a clear
example of you know a guy that doesn't
know much about health he's a brilliant
businessman huh okay and the medical
doctor you know because he's going up
there getting this checkup every year
you know you have a high PSA test that
means prostate cancer is you know
happening or it's in your future really
quickly we need to take the courageous
approach you know and we're going to
remove that prostate yeah Cades side
effects may be sexual dysfunction you
you know you've been urinary bladder
incontinence you know you're you're in
deep trouble
so you're a great guy yeah but he took
the heroic approach BAM before his
family okay okay so then you know and
the guy still works out everything else
ten years later the SPSA starts to rise
again Annie goes to the medical doctor
and he says you know dude you said this
would never be a problem so you removed
my prostate well we know much more now
than we did them yeah I saw what kind of
answer could he possibly get what do
they think well I told him I said if
you're really concerned about PSA I gave
him some data on it how it's a
completely inaccurate test and I said
don't eat cheese for a month you know
and give up any animal products go
vegetarian and he said you know would
that work the PSA went right down Wow
and in what do you think I mean the
people that are in the system now that
don't know much about health you mean
the average person going to see doctors
or doctors themselves both because the
doctors don't know either yeah I mean
they're taught I'd be 50% of everything
they're taught in the schools and this
was I think Ellucian leap said it a
medical doctor in 50% everything taught
in medical schools is wrong they know
it's wrong but they don't know what half
you know why don't you got what didn't
you know that the body was intelligent
and and that the drug culture only
started in like 1900 when you start
understanding the stuff that you're
talking about you look at stuff like
that in such a different way yeah well
my people just laugh and they've got
this this like video series fails uh-huh
and one of my dogs in the office he
watches it all the time yeah and and you
know you see a couple of funny ones then
all of a sudden you think oh god no yeah
you know it's it's it's bad is it first
of all with the three stressors are
there any of those three categories are
they all ranked even yes okay so they're
all ranked even so so for chemical and
emotional let's talk a couple of those
you you live your life through the
nervous system that means your
perception of the environment
is gonna dictate whether you're gonna
get an attack or run away or repair
tissue of his your body's never static
okay so your metabolism is going to
either regenerate or work on the immune
system which is metabolically expensive
or you're going to flee or fight
okay here's he got the autonomic
sympathetic and parasympathetic it's a
physical chemical emotional stress all
gonna activate that so it's all in the
autonomic response okay so now you get
the emotional response okay so if I show
you a picture of a roller coaster and
you like him
you're gonna initiate this chemical
response which emotions are chemicals
secreted by the brain and if you like
roller coasters you're gonna have
dopamine serotonin you're gonna have
toasting you'd have all this joy you're
gonna be like happy okay I see a picture
of roller coaster and I go holy moly
adrenaline cortisol okay that's not
nephron easy oh yeah it's like people
that are on a plane one person's
enjoying it the other person just
clamors is quite enough right so all of
this stuff happens so if someone has a
fight-or-flight sort of response in
their in their nervous system and then
their brain and they're thinking about
these things how long does it does it
matter or does it vary with each person
in terms of how long those chemicals in
the body affect like if you and I are
both exposed to someone who points a gun
to our head right now
well I dissipate that negative emotion
quicker than Kate or vice versa it
depends on how long you process because
once adrenaline is released it doesn't
it doesn't there's not like a shutoff it
has to be utilized and then run through
so it depends on how much your adrenal
glands are going to be produced in it
and also probably also how much you run
through that event in your mind right
mm-hmm and you stay and you keep it
running as a background subconscious
thought and that causes you to be
stressed so people are walking around is
Oh at PTSD I mean that's all that is
right and that's the weird thing because
people don't know that you can reprogram
your emotional state okay there's
there's like when when you're talking
about post-traumatic stress disorder and
that could be at various levels from
abuse and a childhood or a trauma that
you had as an adult or you know some
type of past incident doesn't just have
to be war and so it's a post trauma
that's ingrained in your brain like the
post trauma that you had when you were
flying or we're on the roller coaster
long term emotional stress by reprogram
the brain it's like you know you smell
fresh-baked sourdough bread and then
Michael goes crazy because we used to
beat him with sourdough bread I know
it's so strange how he has these
responses he's got cortisol release oh
[Laughter]
but but that's that's the same stimulus
but based on how the brain is programmed
those those neurons are gonna fire in a
certain pattern that's why what we get
yeah hundred percent of the time you've
got to deal with the physical chemical
and emotional stress otherwise people
will not get better so that would be
considered an emotional stress
absolutely yeah so in our course we are
going to identify that problem but also
get people tools to reprogram if I think
that's where people get stuck I mean you
can hear all this they're like oh but
how do you reprogram your brain right
like most people don't know how to do
that that's the cool path it's super
easy okay but it's reprogram the
subconscious you don't have to believe
it and the subconscious is programmed
through repetition uh-huh and and you
know there's so many different I mean
there's EMDR eye movement
desensitization response there's eft
there's neuro linguistic programming I
mean there's so many different avenues
now so what you have to do is when these
people are getting better if they just
get little twinge all of a sudden they
get this emotional release of like oh my
god that's the start of this cascade of
yuck that I won't be able to stand for
more than three minutes you know yeah
instead of so we reprogram that so if
they just get a little twinge they just
think that's a little twinge no big deal
don't buy into it don't buy into it then
so you fire off different neurons yeah
and that's that's why a physical
stressor we can reshape the spy
you can reenergize you know the body you
can rehydrate the disk you can
strengthen muscles that are weak you can
learn new sleep patterns and you can
have altered biomechanics during the day
the emotional stress you can reprogram
that okay change your perception of
those environments
I could probably teach myself to like
roller coasters if so like you are the
master of your own health the master of
your own emotions you get to choose the
thoughts that you have I mean this isn't
easy for me either I'm working on it
we're all working on it we're all
forever yeah it's a forever process
right one of the main problems with with
how we view health now we we have it
segmented into cardiology and
endocrinology and in ob/gyn you know all
that there's no way that ob/gyn without
a knowledge of of nutrition without a
knowledge of stress levels did he go
over how to sleep at night they to go
over walking every day to do go over
grounding no and and because he doesn't
he's not a holistic fashion ER right
anybody that's not holistic that's
segmented like that is wrong a hundred
years from now okay or 200 years from
now I'm guessing a hundred years because
I got a positive attitude about public
that that there it's gonna be it's like
redundant I mean it's like saying yeah
the sun's gonna come up tomorrow yeah
clouds are not it has to be holistic
there's no way that you can look at a
segmental aspect I mean what does your
cardiologist say this is he talking
about digestion sleep patterns or
nutrition no then he should go pump gas
or learn about the whole body what does
the gastroenterologist do right is he
talking about your autonomic nervous
system is he asking you about your sleep
patterns No
then he should go pump gas too because
they shouldn't be working on humans if
you're not looking at the whole body
then you should not be in this process
even though that they're training their
you know for years of whatever they have
bachelor they got the four years of
medical school okay and they should
understand
that the body is connected you know
chemical stress so let's let's end with
the chemical stressors like what's the
the main sort of chemical stressors that
were dealing with the biggest one is
sleep really as a chemical I think I
think lack of sleep would be the biggest
chemical more so than vaccine or more so
than than anything I mean you could
because vaccines you could choose to do
or not to do okay and based on education
you know when you look at the risk and
benefit of having a foreign substance
injected into you and its response I
mean if you look at the I'm off loes
influenza okay that really does work
okay it decreases that Hamas flow ends
with influenza B however what's the end
result well we're seeing a massive rise
okay in other their called non typable
Haemophilus influenzae so we're seeing a
massive rise and other diseases from
that okay you know you're talking a
decrease in some of the diseases that
they're vaccinating for we get the
sickest population in the world one in
two American kids has a chronic illness
or disease so when you look into you
know not just that little segmental
thing of Wow is it gonna stop this
bacteria or virus yeah what's the end
result you know we got a really sick
population okay so the vaccines that's
education okay when we kind of educated
that your body is intelligent and then
you work with the immune system not to
force it into something and that you
have a harmony with all these viruses
and bacteria then that's cool okay sleep
okay if you cannot get deep sleep your
body can't regenerate and that puts you
in a chemically stress state a chronic
fight-or-flight State and so many people
are not sleeping correctly they're
watching TV right before bed there they
have the TV on okay they get up three or
four nights to pee or you know time
status happy you know they're there they
don't wake up refreshed they're
exhausted they could fall asleep at a
stoplight yeah you know you know they're
they're not they're not waking up in the
morning feeling vibrant refreshed and
and ready to take on the day
they're exhausted they're hoping to get
through it yeah because they're not
taught that if you watch TV or
electronics or you know something before
bed that the blue light interrupts
melatonin they're not taught to prepare
the mind for sleep they're not taught to
prepare their environment for sleep but
those those other things like the
chemical stressors of food medications
vaccines
those are real real oddness and then
then the environmental you know a
chemical stressor from alternate
electric you know EMF right right you
know that you get those frequencies that
can damage I mean there's tons of
Studies on cell phones at a Europe at
how damaged and they are and they even
have it listed by brand so so sleep
obviously chemicals and how to detox and
the the neat part is your body is always
regenerate I mean every red blood cell
you got man every 120 days brand new so
you're talking blood disorders can go
away quickly
you know musculoskeletal joints they're
they regenerate every every 18 months
you got skin every 30 days you've got
you've got everything so dynamic so you
make those little tiny changes and your
body will regenerate the tissue that's
what's so cool so the people don't know
that they think I've got a disease and
that's it but man you can really have
the like the power to heal really is
ours
that do you know how many times I've had
to talk with patients who have had type
2 diabetes and and I tell him that
within 30 to 45 days they're not going
to have it anymore the blood Sugar's
gonna be normal
they'll say well this is totally
different recommendations and my doctor
is managing my diabetes and I say yeah I
don't want to manage it I just want to
fix it well I managed something is not
there anymore that's what's so cool
about the human body is that the same
like there's a doctor that said you know
you cannot heal in the same environment
that you got sick in that's really
interesting so it's our environment you
know not just that where we live and
what we do and where we work but it's
also our internal environment our
physical or our spiritual environment
what we allow in so the environment
needs to be changed on all levels and
what's amazing is that we really can't
heal
yes if you're really if you really want
to heal you could do chronic disease is
epidemic in America
and it is increasing the national debt
and threatening to bankrupt the United
States government it has to be a
bottom-up revolution with individual
people deciding that they are going to
be healthy
and doing that most people don't really
think about health actively I mean most
people just live their life and and
don't think much about health you are
responsible for your health no one else
I'm not your doctor isms nobody is I'm
gonna educate myself and I'm gonna learn
how to get well how to stay well how to
never be sick again there is no
compelling reason why anyone should have
any of these chronic diseases so I went
to these 36 top specialists and all they
did was send a bill and come up with
fancy Latin names for what I told them
in English and the last one finally said
hoo boy I can help you take this drug
and I took the drug the drug poison my
liver my liver died and my death was a
medical certainty at the last moment I
had to use my knowledge of biochemistry
to save my life why do people get sick
how do people get sick if they have a
sick person how do you make them a
healthy person I started to get answers
to these questions and the answers was
so profound they just blew me away
six months into this I realized that
what we call modern medicine is
essentially unscientific nonsense
and worthless it doesn't work it's very
expensive it's very dangerous and it's
already on the way out I'm a highly
trained scientist and I was able to use
my scientific training to help myself
and I've simplified health and disease
so that anybody can do it anybody can do
it I teach this to 10 year olds people
all over the world have bought my books
with terminal illnesses I wrote a book
on how to cure cancer people around the
worlds with terminal cancer buy that
book cost $15 they go home they cure
their cancer she said I had rheumatoid
arthritis and I was crippled and you
cured me I didn't do anything she cured
herself all you have to do is learn very
simple system so in this power is
available to you if you're willing to
accept the responsibility to learn how
to do it so now we don't have to worry
about thousands of diseases there's only
one disease a cell is a unit of life all
of us started life as one single cell in
our mother because you really aren't a
body what you really are is a community
of trillions of cells acting together to
make you who you are so what is disease
well disease is when a cell is not
functioning normally now when you were
one single cell on your mother if that
cell was malfunctioning you were sick
and it's the same thing today when you
have cells at a malfunctioning you're
sick and the more cells that you have
that a malfunctioning the sicker you are
I would know what was wrong with someone
before they came through the door
because I know this only one disease
malfunctioning cell
now the doctor doesn't know that they
have to go into the doctor the doctor
has to do all sorts of fancy testing and
then the doctor finally comes back and
says you have diabetes well what good is
that it's a useless piece of information
so there's one disease malfunctioning
cell there's two causes of disease
deficiency and toxicity this is the
essence of this very simple simple
system and once you incorporate that
into your thinking the power is awesome
all you have to do is keep your cells
functioning normally
and if they're not restore them to
normal function
so my question Avene is how on earth do
we make illness a choice well most of
our health we talk about really comes
from these chronic diseases and the
chronic diseases are where there's a
Parkinson's Alzheimer's when you look at
depression anxiety or you look at OCD
ADHD obesity diabetes cancer or even all
the autoimmune diseases every one of
them is caused by one simple thing which
is a chronic inflammation and when your
body is out of balance it is at not at
ease and which is what we call disease I
mean if you think about us we are a
walking talking ecosystem so if you
think from is in a spiritual perspective
or you think about from a larger
universe perspective we humans are part
of this larger ecosystem we call
environment we as humans our environment
in ourselves the trillions of
microorganisms inside us we are a
ecosystem and when our ecosystem gets
damaged because we are feeding in the
wrong thing then our body essentially
starts to suffer the thing that's most
interesting is that it's only now that
we are able to understand what is going
on inside our body
it used to be completely a black box and
people always felt for the time they
always wanted to eat healthy but the
problem was no one knew what was healthy
and so you would come up with these fad
diets but you start to look at the Paleo
diet and you start to look at the
ketogenic diet and the left-hand diet
and you know every day there is a new
fad diet the fact is you and I share
almost the identical DNA 99.9% of our
DNA is identical when it comes to our
organism our environment inside our body
less than 5% is the same and that's the
reason there is no such thing called
inflammatory food or on a healthy food
because if food that's healthy for you
may not be healthy for someone else
in fact the food that's healthy for you
today may not be healthy for you in
three months then explain to me why
exactly that is yes so first of all if
you think about it that our bodies are
extremely unique as I said and our
ecosystem inside the gut so every time
you eat food what's the first thing is
being encountered is encountered by the
microbiome and depending on their
ecosystem they're able to metabolize
that food and either produce the
nutrients that your body needs or it can
produce the toxins that actually hurt
the body and inflame the body so for
example is spinach most people who think
is spinach is healthy it turns out a
spinach is not healthy for me and the
reason is if spinach has lot of oxalate
and if you don't have the oxalobacter
and you got it actually not going to be
matter oxalate cannot be metabolized by
the gut microbiome that means it's now
being fed by someone else who is going
to cut create and lipeh polysaccharides
which is LPS which is going to cause
inflammation in your body so it turns
out that as we have gone through not
tens of thousands of people in are
things we find thirty percent of the
people in our system today in fact
spinach is harmful to them luzhin yeah
and more than interesting thing is fifty
percent of the people that we see that
think or polyphenol everybody thinks the
pomegranate juice is good for them or
the walnuts are good for them or you
know the blueberries are good for them
all of these are really good for about
half the people other half you're simply
wasting your money it does nothing other
than stressing and harming your body
because you do not have the right
organisms to be able to digest them so
unlike everyone else in this field that
has come before us nobody has been able
to see what these microbes are actually
doing okay so okay now you think of us
as a shell and it gets that whole notion
of we're less than 1% human just really
fast explain that so basically we have
more foreign cells in our body than the
human self when it comes to gene
expression our human DNA only expresses
about 20,000 genes and the microbiome in
our gut it produces about 22 million to
20 million genes so
best to be a 1% human from a gene
expression perspective or worse we
appoint you 1% you left which is really
crazy and most people do not understand
that and and I wouldn't have understood
it we'll talk more about Lisa later I
certainly would not have understood that
until seeing what she was going through
and trying to figure that out and I had
to change my metaphor I had to think of
the microbiome first I had to start
thinking about being an ecosystem so all
right we've got this shell it's
expressing one percent roughly of the
genes that are active in within that
shell but I've been wooden that I want
to also talk about that one percent and
you know most people think of our DNA as
our destiny our genes are our destiny it
turns out the genes are really not your
destiny
it is obviously your microbiome but even
within the genes it is a gene expression
that counts not the genes in themselves
and here's what I mean by that every
part of our body has identical DNA so
are here are you know skin or lung you
know our heart everything has the same
DNA but they're completely different it
is the expression of the same DNA that
causes the thing to be what they are
so that means Nature has put together
something called epigenetically that
means you can control what genes are
expressed what genes are over Express or
under Express and here is more into
interesting part the therapy for cancer
whether it works or it kills you depends
on your microbiome so the - this is your
microbiome of the microbiome of the
cancer your microbiome so it's very
interesting when you take a drug whether
it's a chemotherapy or it's
immunotherapy so chemotherapy drug
whether it actually works or completely
creates toxins are depends on your
microbiome that leaves the microbiome is
metabolize and analyzing these
chemotherapy drugs and sometime it turns
them into poison that is guaranteed to
kill you other time it detoxifies it it
doesn't kill cancer or it actually
amplifies and allows it to kill cancer
right immunotherapy the same way they
found the certain microbes that the
microbiome would make it 10x more
impactful for immune system to attack
the cancer or it actually doesn't so
whether even not just the cancer is
caused by a microbe on whether the
cancer treatment works or does not work
depends on your microbiome they found
the same thing with PTSD they found the
depression is obviously the inflammatory
disease and when you fix your gut I mean
even our customers lemon we don't go out
as well ever cure a disease we fix the
inflammation and we fix the balance and
you gut and some people will tell us
that he I had depression he's gone I had
anxiety it is gone I had acne it is gone
and there were two women who went on dr.
oz show and one of them lost 71 pounds
we were not trying to happen happen
whose weight
we simply she had inflammation and fix
inflammation people have autoimmune
diseases IBD IBS we go through these
diseases which are simply the names we
give to certain set of symptoms the fact
is all of these diseases are fundamental
chronic inflammation that can be
controlled to your diet right so the
trick really is not saying what is a
healthy food you need to say it's not
about the food it's about me what's
healthy for me not what's a healthy food
because like hypocrite he said right all
diseases begin in the gut
one man's food is another man's poison
so his spinach could be good for you it
could be toxin for you and then he said
let food be thy medicine
let thy medicine be the food and we
forgotten that 25 years ago so like for
instance if Lisa doesn't meditate in the
morning who doesn't sometimes he
meditate right before she eats just
eating will upset her stomach you know
it's just safe food yeah but meditating
makes a difference so so do you remember
that our body is not a one-way tunnel it
is a bi-directional things like so the
stress that we have causes our
microbiome to change and when your
microbiome is upset it causes us to be
stressed or anxious or depressed right
so how what's the mechanist the
mechanism is you know the in depression
or anxiety is the inflammation right so
when you your microbiome is releasing
things like lipopolysaccharides they are
absorbed in the blood that causes the
immune system to have a low-grade
inflammation and the low-grade
inflammation is what causes you to be
depressed right for
is it or how does it how does
inflammation have so many varied
responses yeah so think about it
inflammation is like you know a constant
body in Alaric's situation so your
immune system is constantly alert and
one way for it to kill what they think
is the enemy is to create the
inflammation so it can engulf it and
essentially destroy it right but you
have that thing was really really good
when you actually had some communicable
disease or when you were trying to do
fight or flight for stress like it was
really good for body to get ready to
fight or flight right but when you are
in living in a modern society when you
are now stress is being caused by
relationships ice caused by because you
work environment is not right or you
know monetary thing or in number of
other reasons what happens to your body
is constantly on that alert and it's
constantly releasing the cortisol and
your microbiome is saying first thing
went by the way when you go into fight
or flight response is your digestive
system shuts down so the by meditating
what you're doing is taking the
qualities all levels to essentially down
and that allows the body and the
microbiome to be essentially saying ok
you'll no longer in that fight-or-flight
response let's start the digestive
system again why sometimes depression
why sometimes anxiety why sometimes
cancer like how can inflammation
manifest in so many different ways so
first of all let's start the last part
first if you look at the chronic
inflammation it's not localized right so
your whole body is under inflammation
and when your body's under stress this
is all connected it always breaks at the
weakest link right so if your whole body
that is like think of it like a chain
and it's at this point when there is
under stress the weakest part of the
chain will break first so let's assume
you've been drinking a lot and you have
inflammation boom your liver is the
first one to go right so if depending on
wherever the weakest thing is for other
reasons in your life that whatever the
weakest sub component is that is the
first one to break right and that's the
reason you find them in a different the
same type of inflammation may cause
obesity in one
diabetes in someone else it may cause a
depression in one person it may cause a
autoimmune and someone else right
because at the end of the day depending
on wherever this thing pops up right and
you can and what our pharmaceutical
drugs are basically popping a pop right
you till you essentially put this one
down suppress this symptom it pops up
here and then you get a new set of
symptoms and you suppress that symptom
you pop three more symptoms now and then
now by the time you get to be sixty
years old you're taking more pills for
your breakfast than you need to the
breakfast right here and that's
literally the business model of our
pharmaceutical companies they really
have become to large extent a parasite
on society iiving on these chronic
diseases an interesting thing is chronic
disease are preventable
unlike the communicable diseases you
catch in faction you don't catch obesity
you don't catch your diabetes you don't
catch a depression it is you develop it
over a long period of time
even I I know somebody watching right
now saying this is black magic it's
witch doctor II stuff even I part of it
I'm like oh my god can it really be that
straightforward here's very interesting
one beat any disease and google it for
yourself and read the research paper so
just type in a part in sons and
microbiome type in depression and
microbiome type in autoimmune disease a
microbiome type in cancer and microbiome
type in diabetes and microbiome and you
start to see the impact all the
researches these are done here's another
interesting one
they had a diabetic person who's been
taking metformin drug which is for
diabetes metformin does not work on the
human body it works on the microbiome
okay so it changes your gut microbiome
and here is how we know it because they
took that microbiome the person who's
been taking metformin gave it to the
mice who is diabetic just by
transferring the microbiome it had the
same impact as if the mice was taking
metformin Wow
right because it works on your micro
mind as you know the gut microbiome is
the root cause of all other diseases so
when you fix you I'll get microbiome
you're fixing the cancer and all other
diseases are also impact at the same
time but there's a depression focus ADHD
all those diseases are
basically inflammatory diseases we're
really fastest talk so if I'm not
mistaken your dad was just diagnosed
recently with cancer yeah yeah so walk
me through that like what are you doing
oh my god what if I had started this
company two years ago or three years ago
I would have been little fix it and all
I can do is really at this point I don't
know what to do other than to see and
hope that no one else has to suffer
through it right he has to go through
the chemotherapy like nine is going
through the you know chemotherapy yeah
but just with him three weeks ago and
seeing him you know you know just not be
himself losing constant weight his hair
is gone and he's just shrinking and
watching him just feel his heart really
feels on and he wished something you
could fix I mean and so I saw this
research on pancreatic cancer I called
his oncologist and I said have you seen
this research and he's oh they're so new
and I say why can't you use this and he
says it's not allowed and I'm thinking
what could have done it I can I'm out
thinking I could just tell the doc hey
this research is good do this what is
the harm here but the doctor has ethical
duty that he's not gonna implement
because it's not allowed it's not FDA
approved
so anyway ah my only hope is that
someday and that day will be soon it
will be our generation Tom that will one
day absolutely make this chronic disease
is simply a matter of choice and I'm
absolutely convinced at this point and I
am determined that I'll do whatever it
takes so that no one ever have to suffer
through any chronic diseases and and I
know it is doable and I know we are
finding every single day what causes
these diseases and how we can modulate
these diseases simply through diet and
we're gonna look back at these movements
five years ten years from now
and we don't realize that we were the
first generation that wiped off the
chronic diseases from the face of this
earth and someday people who look at our
generation is the one that used the
exponential technologies to create
abundance of energy created abundance of
food and solved all of the global grand
challenges that I've been facing our
species the human species for
generations and we're gonna solve that
what at a really high generic level and
I know there is no universal diet and I
totally get that yeah but like at a high
level what are directional advice that
you have for people of how to eat like
cycling eating's wide variety I mean
again this is exactly what caused all
the problems we have because we want to
simplify and tell people treat your body
like a black box and if you just keep
feeding things into it somehow magic
will happen but the fact is you can't
treat like a black box you have to know
what is going on if they're not
producing the right set of nutrients you
have to feed those guys what the
nutrients your body needs so if you're
not getting enough good stuff the
vitamins and then butyrate short chain
fatty-acids you've got to feed them or
you have to take that enzymes to
essentially make up for it so you can't
just sit here I'm eating healthy because
I'm eating spinach I'm eating kale our
meeting our kettle guess what that may
be exactly what's wrong for you just
like me you know mice like I thought I
was eating healthy because I was trying
to lose weight
I was trying I was pre-diabetic and I
always thought eating is spinach avocado
oats cut down all the gluten cut down
all the carbs cut down all the starch
and guess what happened for the first
few months I lost weight and I was my
blood glucose was going down and I was
happy I continued with that diet guess
what happened I got gained all the way
back and my blood glucose is going back
up again when I did my own test it turns
out I need to be eating 50% of my diet
as a complex carbohydrate I had to cut
down spinach avocado oats star eating
more wheat good good time and start
eating lot of the other food that I
never eaten so everything your blood
Sugar's ensure my blood sugar is went
down my doctors thinks that
must be on some drug that I'm not
telling her she says keep doing whatever
you doing but it's working I used to
take nexium which was killing me I cut
down all the nexium and I thought she
was gonna be so angry at me she said I'm
so glad you're taking nexium because now
you don't have the stomach acid problem
and by the way you were any makin you
you know your iron was no it's our back
to normal now so just keep doing what
you doing keep taking those drugs that I
gave you what she didn't know is I
stopped all of them and I think is very
interesting thing is a lot of the food
sensitivities go away because food
sensitivities when you measure its
diversity in measuring the antibodies in
the blood the reason you get antibodies
in the blood is because the blood is
seeing the stuff in the blood because
your system leaking yeah you got so if
you have a leak you got your immune
system is going to see these food in the
thing it creates the antibodies and you
think you're allergic to it
yeah yeah that sounds super fun I'm
looking at my wife right now who at one
point because she they didn't know she
had a key gun yeah they were like
essentially you're allergic to
everything and she's not right once you
fix the leaky gut for only six months
later these antibodies die away and then
cirno's you no longer allergic to them
yes literally what happens yeah and you
know to me that is the key is to
understand that you know hey why are
people talking [ __ ] nowadays it's
because everyone wants to know about
their microbiome like other thing is
really understanding the snapshot of
what is that your microbiome doing are
they actually working for you or they
working against you so knowing your
superfoods and your knowing your
kryptonite's what food is going to cause
these guys to produce toxins and the
stuff that is not going to be good for
your body and what food is going to
allow these guys to produce the
nutrients our body needs so so what we
do is we give you your superfoods we
give you your kryptonite and give you
the foods you should be eating more of
and the foods you should be minimizing
and the food you should be avoiding and
as I said it's really different for
different people for me and my wife is
completely opposite
I should be avoiding spinach and oats
and
avocado she needs to be eating her super
foods very interesting is that she and I
are completely different
[Music]
but as things pop the
we need to keep our channels open so I'm
just gonna show a couple really simple
well this help folks with allergies
absolutely here's a couple really simple
techniques for allergies so every
morning when you wake up you go to the
bathroom wash your face brush your teeth
just throw this into the mix just about
ten times stick your thumb right in the
base of your nose you're gonna rub up
kind of firm rub up to about the middle
of your forehead just about 10-15 times
huh all the way up yeah all the way up
do that about ten or fifteen times then
you're going to bring your fingers right
to the corners of your nose you're gonna
press in and rub out about ten or
fifteen times do that before my makeup
because I wipe my makeup so it's best
first thing in the morning and that what
this is gonna do is it's gonna help open
up the sinus but it also stimulates the
nerve plexuses in here it helps to
balance out the endocrine system so this
helps the body basically change with the
season instead of being a disharmony
with this season the body harmonizes
what you see so you do that every
morning I do it just not in spring no I
do it every morning in the spring it's
most important just because there's a
lot more stuff in the air and they want
to keep especially these passages open
my name is Mathias and I'm an injured
dumbass I am just a regular Dutch guy
and I played football and I stepped into
a hole and my knee snapped back and from
that moment on I just I'm struggling
with physical injuries forms six years
now and I've seen physio after physio
after physio I had a knee surgery
I saw a chiropractor about a therapist
and none of them were able to help me
with my injuries and when your I was 21
during the time and when nobody can help
you and you get into a black hole
this method helped me get back on my
feet and smile and feel that I hive
again and I'm very grateful for what
this pathology brought to me
think about it chemical medicines were
discovered just about a hundred to two
hundred years ago people still used to
heal themselves of illnesses before that
right they knew something that we have
lost in my family
not a single medicine has entered since
the past two years we do fall sick every
now and then but we cure everything
through five simple steps step number
one stop eating and fast
this means no solid food just water and
fresh juices you probably afraid of the
word fasting but let me tell you it's
not as difficult as it sounds when you
fall sick your taste buds change it's
not like you have to you know stop
yourself you don't feel like eating
nature takes away your natural hunger
it's her way of saying hey I'm doing
some deep cleaning within you not
interrupted by giving me food to digest
even animals fast when they're sick
they're more instinctive than we are
when my dog falls sick no matter how
much food I give him he won't eat it
till he's fine again
I went down some wrong paths with drug
addiction and depression anxiety my
health was suffering my family
relationships were suffering everything
was you know collapsing before me you
know with the wim HOF method that sort
of turned everything around
and to me where half was the ultimate
for me because I I feel he saved my life
it's dr. Berke here in this short video
i'm going to show you how to get rid of
a sore throat within two minutes without
pills herbs drugs so it sound good and I
know my you might be thinking this is
too good to believe but it actually
really works and I want you to prove it
on yourself I wish I knew this back when
I had sore throats growing up I had a
move almost every four months especially
in the winter they kept coming
this technique is all acupressure and I
developed it and I'm gonna teach you how
to do it now you can do it to yourself
or you can have someone do it and I'm
gonna teach you both ways here's the
principle of how it works if you were to
point to the sore throat just pretend he
doesn't have a sore throat but let's
let's say he did he's pointing right to
his Adam's apple right here and it's
usually gonna be in the middle mid part
of the neck and then what happens we're
gonna draw a line in the back part of
his neck right here and we're gonna be
pressing inward exactly on the opposite
side of where the sore throat is now why
does that work because pain and
inflammation is kind of a stuck energy
that's stuck in the front by pressing
the opposite of frees up the lymphatic
system increases the circulation
increases the nerve flow to free up
through there so not only will the sore
throat go away within one to two minutes
when doing this but you'll find that it
won't keep coming back which is very
very cool so I'm going to show you how
to do it you're gonna use your your
middle finger here and your thumb and
we're going to press right on the middle
part and we're gonna stabilize the
forehead and press inward like this like
a scissoring effect and you're gonna
press nice and firmly now the way you
know you have the correct points is that
it's going to be very very very tender
on this back part way more tender than
where here it's an sore throat but that
pain is going away and and what'll
happen it to feel a lot better and you
might have to do it the next day or the
next day but you'll find that it's it's
the best thing to do for sore throats
hello I am Andrea and I am a massage
therapist and personal trainer for 10
years I have been practicing boxing
until I got sick of diabetics when I was
19 which I controlled pretty well but
after this week I've noticed a big
improvement in my health my glucose has
been much lower and by practice in the
breathing exercise
I had a great improvement in my health
and in my control of diabetics and I
noticed that my endurance is better my
strength is better as well and my
recovery time is even shorter
[Music]
your body is only going to raise blood
pressure if there's a toxic deficient
environment does that make sense could
you hold that up that that that blood
thinner you have there yes it's a
mixture of two gases hydrogen and oxygen
they form this liquid called what was
that water yes that's a good blood
thinner honest-to-god see there are
doctors out there that get the big
picture
good god they're not popular but you
know they're out there so the doctor
goes in and says yeah high blood
pressures the leading cause of strokes
it's not it's the leading clue to people
that are aware that your blood isn't
healthy of what it does Jesus you know
we got to fix the body clean up the
blood clean up the act and the body gets
better so this is what you do to protect
yourself from strokes okay no oh no I
was gonna put a sign up that said don't
poison yourself okay fill your body with
healthy nutrients
and I was at a time where I just came
from a warm climate I lived in a warm
climate for the last six years and the
the day I moved back to Europe I got ill
immediately I've had information I've
had an infection of my tonsils so I
checked out this website and I found wim
HOF method so he invited me over to
stage which was super cool he made me
breathe forty times and then I pulled
off 60 pushups which was ridiculous
I've never done 60 push-ups ever I would
recommend to people that you should keep
an open mind
towards everything in life but
especially the things that involve your
body and things that are so primal and
so basic I think everyone should have an
open mind about what happens to your
body and how you can heal yourself from
the inside without any other influence
from other other people so always keep
an open mind and truly believe in
yourself
this video I'm gonna share with you my
top supplements and natural carpal
tunnel treatments that you're gonna see
a results with very quickly oftentimes
raising up your desk raising up your
computer screen and getting your body in
a tight comfortable position at a
computer that really is step number one
and then I want to talk about some other
things you can do in terms of natural
treatment now if you're going to see a
physician about carpal tunnel
I would actually highly recommend a
chiropractor and a chiropractor can
actually work on adjusting the wrist
bones and realigning that carpal that
that area that tunnel area one of the
things you can do yourself in terms of
treatment is traction out your wrist
before you just hold onto a weight and
let it traction itself one of the first
things you need to do is start taking
some good quality supplements now it's
been proven in medical research that
vitamin b6 and vitamin b12 are the most
effective vitamins for helping out
carpal tunnel and really those support
your nervous tissue and help it heal and
regenerate
okay so yeah I've been doing the wim HOF
method now for ten months
I suffered from chronic asthma so
hospital three four times every year
called Sol injections three different
inhalers and since doing went off this
is the first year I've not been admitted
into hospital and for six or seven
months now I've I've thrown away on my
medication thank you thank you
radagast that it's gone it's gone it's
gone
I think the way to beat mental health is
setting goals giving yourself short term
and long term goals
I don't suffer with mental health when
I'm active one I've got a goal and I
think most people will vote for this if
you suffer mental problems you tend to
suffer them when you're on your own when
you've got a lot of time to think and
when you're not doing much but when
you're busy on a daily basis you don't
have enough time to think about mental
health and I figured out well if I
exhaust myself in the gym I come on one
I'm too tired to think about anything I
just want to get some food and go to bed
so that's why I do so you didn't use
medication I didn't use medication no I
was I was prescribed with medication
from the doctor but I refused to take it
I took a couple of pills help myself
relax from the doctor but never took
them again I only ever talked a couple
my grandfather me dance dad he was
addicted to pills his whole life pills
that didn't even do anything for him
there was placebo pills both out to me
come function really so I didn't want to
become one of them
healed my eyesight in about two weeks
from 2040 to 2025 that's around a two
lines improvement in an eye chart they
want to know my secrets I was in a
conversation with my friend Dave Asprey
be famous biohacker the founder of
bulletproof coffee and they've told me
how working with a vision coach for one
hour a week for 12 weeks totally got rid
of his bad eyesight and allowed him to
function without glasses I was intrigued
so I started researching the natural
healing of eyesight some studies on
children found that a child could
naturally move from shortsightedness to
farsightedness year over year but here's
what happens if you pick that particular
slice of time where your eyesight is say
0.25 and you go to an optician and you
get glasses for that it locks you in the
glasses become a crutch after you get
your actual prescription from the doctor
get a lens that is one step lower
because like I said your eyesight
actually fluctuates you could be at 0.5
and one day when you're really stressed
out and after a relaxing weekend your
eyesight could actually improve studies
are now finding that emotional states
that stress influences your vision so if
your doctor tells you that your eyesight
is safe point 5 myopia shortsightedness
don't get a point 5 lens get a lens
that's 0.25 that will still give you an
adjustment but it gives you room for
your vision to improve now the next
thing you want to do is that you want to
install a basic chart in your home so I
have something like this on the door of
my study William horrorshow Bates who
lived in the early part of the 20th
century did a study on school classrooms
he would hang an eye chart on a pillar
in school classrooms and what he found
is that in classrooms where kids had
that eye chart and the teachers were
trained to get the kids to go and just
look at the chart and see how far they
could read once a week the amount of
cases of nearsightedness was
dramatically reduced now the final tip
is this higher vision coach or take an
online vision course their numerous
vision courses out there I've been
experimenting with many of them I even
have a vision coach who has helped me
was spent around five hours together and
the results have been really really
really promising so I'm not much of a
philosopher but it was volt
we said something very important and
that's the art of medicine consists of
amusing the patient while nature cures
the disease
hey guys Jerez here longtime
collaborator of evans you may or may not
know me I made this video because people
like Evan and my dad and you deserve
easier health that's just it it's time
for health beliefs to rise I hope you
enjoyed it thanks so much for watching
much love so I used to get sick a lot
I remember having multiple discussions
with Jia Rhys about health ideas belief
system strategies and then three years
ago or so I got really sick super sick I
had hiccups for five days remember that
it's crazy five days of like 5-hour out
of time hiccups that would just not go
away and I decided this is crazy I need
to stop getting sick I used to have a
belief system that if you were sick you
came around me I would get sick like
this has to end I need to figure out
this health thing I remember seeing a
video of Gary Vee talking about how he
just decided that he would not get sick
anymore and it worked I started putting
up sticky notes above my door saying
don't get sick remember
I'm always healthiest otherwise I'm
always healthy I'm always healthy and
then Jay Rhys also put me on to wim hof
where Nina and I went to his workshop
here in Toronto and sat in the ice baths
and she she sat in the ice bath way
longer than I did you did a great job
didn't he she was crazy that was great
and and I haven't really been sick since
then I've gotten sick maybe what twice
in the past three years it's been crazy
and so this video that Jo has put
together is a step further and and I
just believed that people need to stop
getting sick I think believe nation if
you learn anything from this if you can
apply it to your life and you bring more
health to yourself that translates to
more energy for your business for your
family for the work that you're trying
to do I hope I hope I hope some of this
content resonates with you and you could
take it back dive deeper into the world
to the people that that we profile to
you today thank you so much for watching
I'd love to know the results that you
get after taking some of the steps
outlined in this video and if you want
to see my personal journey with wim hof
at his workshop in Toronto we documented
the whole thing the link is right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
I'm a man on a mission I don't stop
until we have no war anymore no disease
no depression yeah
[Applause]